foreign
you
good morning everyone i've been told
that the live streaming
apparatus in this room begins operation
promptly at the time that the committee
session is scheduled for
therefore i'm assuming that the live
stream is now live and so we are going
to start
this morning's committee meeting
and as always we will begin our
commuting committee meeting by asking
you all to rise and joining us as
representative thomas leads us in the
pledge of allegiance the flag is over
here
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
thank you representative thomas and
thank you all for being here this
morning
so the agenda for today is we have five
bills to hear
we'll talk a little bit about the first
one in a minute
we have four bills scheduled starting at
12 30
1 30 2 30 and 3 30.
and it is always our goal to be complete
so that is our agenda for today
and i'm going to talk a little bit more
about our first bill in a minute
before i do that though i want to remind
the members of the committee about
microphone etiquette
it is always important for you to turn
your mic on before you speak
get fairly close to the mic before you
speak
if you sit
way back here
people aren't going to be able to hear
you as effectively as if you sit here
after you spin it finish speaking
please turn your mic off
that's our mike etiquette
lesson for today
i'd also like to remind committee
members of our committee procedures for
conducting these hearings
we are all aware that we're here to
gather information
we're not here to debate the people who
are presenting information we're not
here to debate each other
all we're here to do today is ask
questions
and
listen carefully to the answers to
accumulate information about the
subjects
and now on to our first meeting our
so i'd like to open the public hearing
on house bill
1644 which is relative to the placement
of telecommunications antenna
and establishing a registry for
residents who are experiencing
biological symptoms
now i would remind everybody who is
signed up to testify and we have 20 pink
cards indicating there are 20 people who
want to testify today
i would remind everyone that this is the
science technology and energy committee
we're looking for scientific data and
scientific evidence
to support the reasoning behind this
bill we're not particularly interested
in
people's personal health experiences
unless they can be backed up with
scientific data from a doctor or a
research lab
to verify that their medical conditions
are caused
by
exposure to
cell phone towers and other sources of
smart meters and other sources of
radiation
because we have so many people signed up
we're going to have to impose limits on
people's testimony
so to begin our
session this morning we're going to
allow
representative patrick abrami to
introduce the bill and he will have 12
minutes
to
introduce the bill
subsequent to that everybody who
testifies will be given three minutes to
testify
so summarize your testimony as
succinctly as possible
in order to give us a chance to get
through
all 20 people who want to testify here
this morning
21 people now i guess
so
we will be
cutting off this hearing at 11 30 this
morning
if there
if everybody who has signed up to
testify has testified by 11 30 then fine
if there are still people who want to
testify once we get to 11 30 we will
resist recess
this public hearing and we will resume
it at a later date
and that date will be published in the
calendar
so that everybody will know just exactly
when to return to this room to complete
their testimony on the bill
so with that introduction i would now
like to turn it over to representative
patrick abrami to introduce house bill
1644.
thank you mr chair uh for the record uh
statement pata brahmi
rockingham 19 stratum
this bill has to do with cell tower
placement
actually
antenna placement
because these antennas go on things
other than towers as well
and about a registry for radio frequency
sensitive residents
before i discuss the details of the bill
let's talk big picture
it's important to say out front that we
love our cell phones
this is nothing to do about that but we
should as a state ensure the technology
around us is safe
as practically possible
with this bill cell phones will live on
how many members of this committee would
be happy
with a cell tower going up at the edge
of their property line
and not being able to stop it
this happens
frequently in our state
where residents find themselves
hopelessly
without any recourse but to accept a
cell tower going up near their property
my experience in my town shows that
this happens all the time in my my
neighborhoods in stratham my residents
call me
when we're looking at a new cell tower
and most residents argue aesthetics
property values
but most important health concerns
one recent case
that i was involved in in our planning
board we had an electrical engineer who
was
arguing the health concerns
uh but he didn't get very far why didn't
he get very far
those town planning boards eventually
give in
because the fcc is all-powerful because
of the 1996 telecommunication act
before the 2019-20 term the issue of
radio frequency radiation was brought to
my attention especially with the
emergence of 5g
i felt filed a bill to examine this
that bill to a former commission passed
this committee
and on the floor it passed the senate
health and human service committee and
and passed on the senate floor and the
governor signed it that commission
chaired by me met 14
for 14 months produced a 390 page report
that includes the appendices in the
minutes
included before you uh on your desk
that has been cited around the country
and even in federal court case
the wording of our bill
the bill
formed the commission that several
several other states have as well
here were the major conclusions the
federal government and specifically the
fcc and fda have ignored the science
from around the world on negative
effects of radiation
that is
we reached out to the fcc and the fda
who responded but never answered our
questions
the epa basically when we reached out to
them the epa basically said not our job
and besides we have no funding to study
this
so basically there's really no one in
the federal government that is
dealing with this issue
on the health level
our conclusion was that
that one needs to ensure safety of
citizens against over exposure to rf
radiation and we concluded that the
state of new hampshire needs to to
control its own destiny
we concluded that beyond the health
issues it returned some control to the
state of its political and its political
subdivisions just from a planning
standpoint alone should occur
note that note that countries and cities
around the world are also dealing with
this issue
most already have stricter standards on
rf radiation than we do
in the u.s many cities and towns
are working different ordinances to
attempt to retake control of this issue
some have been challenged and others
have not
this is why if you check your your
legislative email
you will find letters of support from
around the country and the world
in the state of california the
firefighters have lobbied for and
achieved exemptions from forced
placement of cell towers
on their fire stations because of health
concerns from radiation
of radiation the 2015 california
assembly bill 57 used the phrase due to
the unique duties and infrastructure
requirements for swift and effective
deployment of firefighters
to get around the fcc
so that no cell antennas could be placed
on or near any fire station
so they came up with a way of getting
around the fcc
so it can be done
in the news recently
is the one federal agency the federal
aviation administration
who understands the science the faa and
aerospace industry groups say tests
show
devices that are calculate altitude
could become
unreliable if aircraft get too close to
5g towers
with that the cell companies have agreed
to delay
the turning on of the 5g service near
airports
there was never a concern with 2g 3g or
4g just as the fte
just as the faa is concerned thousands
of scientists are warning
as we go further up the electromagnetic
spectrum using higher frequency waves
and power density
as 5g does
there will be negative impacts the waves
can alter optimum intermediate readings
then what can they do increase
non-ionization non-ionizing ionizing
radiation
courts have said that the fcc's
interpretation of science
to me ignoring the science is arbitrary
and capricious
it is a wake-up call
i want to point out from the
bill if you if you go to the
uh i hope you read the the uh findings
and purpose
but if you go to line 20 on the first
page
on august 13 2021 the united states
court of appeals for the circuit
district uh
ruled
in a case brought by the environmental
health trust and children's health
defense
that the federal community the federal
communications commission's decision in
2019 2019 that their radio frequency
emission safety guidelines dating back
to 1996 were adequate to protect the
public was arbitrary and capricious
in its failure to respond to
record evidence
and in the violation of federal aviation
procedure act
specifically the court said and then
what's in quotes
is the actual
was
actually in the ruling that failure
undermines the commissions
meaning the the uh
the uh
fcc
concludes regarding the adequacy
of its testing procedures particularly
as it relates to children as conclusions
regarding the implications of long-term
exposure to radio frequency radiation
exposure to radio frequency pulsation
and modulation
and and the implications of technology
developments that have occurred since
all of which depend on the premise that
exposure to radio frequency
at the levels below its current
limits causes no negative health effects
accordingly we find those conclusions
arbitrary and capricious as well finally
we find the commission's order arbitrary
and capricious
in its complete failure to respond to
comments concerning environmental harm
caused by radio frequency radiation
so that's the conclusion of the
court of appeals in the d.c district
i was going to read this today but i
guess i don't have time
this this it's on your desk
from uh
from the executive director of
environment health trust who filed one
of the people who filed the court case
that does a lot more explaining of what
that's again that's before you
so now let's discuss the bill
the first page
the first two
two
two pages plus the top of the next page
is really the
is really the purpose statement
and at the end we conclude public health
and safety is the primary responsibility
of local and state government
the state's rights in this case should
not be superseded by the federal
government
the first of two things in this bill
does
is the is talks about a
telecommunications antenna placement
and this is on the top of
of page three
line starts at line six i'll just read
it to you because it's only three lines
the placement of telecommunication
antennas
on any existing structure existing pole
new pole or tower constructed after the
enactment of this paragraph
shall be
placed at least 1640 feet from
residentially zoned areas parks
playgrounds hospitals nursing homes and
daycares and schools
so first you're going to say well what's
why 1640 feet that's that's 500 meters
and that's where the science has shown
that
health effects diminish after 500 meters
just to give you a reference that's five
and a half football fields
dr kent chamberlain emeritus
chair of the unh department of
electrical and computer engineering
will be testifying on that
so
the the second thing is that
the second thing is that
is to set up a radiation exposure
registry to be maintained by the hhs
which costs borne by the operators of
wireless antennas in in the state
there's three points yes there are
people who are actually radio frequency
sensitive to the point that there is
healthcare icd code
for this
being
on the ways and means committee for 12
years i am aware of many fees
that fund things that are buried in the
cost of the product an example
is that there is a fee per gallon of
home heating oil that the distributors
pay
for things like safe the safe tank
program that doesn't appear in the on
the oil bill at home but is built into
the price of the gallon that is charged
at the wholesale level
in our proposal this fee would be very
small
when distributed across all users and
and wireless devices so we're we're
suggesting that we do a similar thing
uh
in terms of bearing the cost of this
reporting mechanism
the fiscal note indicates that it will
take 750 000 to get this database built
and another 230 000 annually
to to run this
uh it is our position that these
development maintenance costs are
inflated
we can go to unh and give them a hundred
thousand dollar grant or less
to develop a database that would that
i'm sure they would gladly accept
we also feel that the maintenance in the
database could be absorbed the existing
pos staff possibly the addition of four
to six hours per week of someone's time
and because they're there the bill calls
for well not the bill
the fiscal note says that they're
talking about adding uh
two people
okay representative abrami can i just
give me one half a minute please sir
okay one more 30 seconds
finally the idea of database is
independent researchers
will have access to the data to do
analyses we do not we're not asking hhs
to do any of this analyses
you'll be hearing from experts and
citizens alike on the science
why six to sixteen hundred forty feet
the phase of the fcc and fda what is
going on in the worldwide and nationally
on this topic and how local governments
are pushing back
mr chair in conclusion
i know your committee will give full
consideration to this bill if they're at
the full commission if there's a full
committee work session or subcommittee
planned
i will i will be there to help in any
way i can and i will bring experts with
me
so with that i thank you for the time
and and again the there's a couple of
handouts i i gave in addition to the
ones i i held up that
talk about what's going on
federally
why these things are going to the courts
it's because there's a failure on the
part of the federal government to do its
job
in regulating this it's clear
i'm not an alarmist
i i'm
that's not me but when you look at this
as long as i have
you know i've come to the conclusion
that that something needs to be done in
this area thank you mr chair great thank
you
so i'd like to open it up now to uh
questions from the committee and
thank you mr chairman uh thank you uh
representative abrami for your
time
uh just one question i
i know there
it seems like the fcc
has been looking the other way on this
is that true in other countries do we
some kind of
something to look at
where they have
taken
to understanding this a little more
thoroughly
well they have because they're
most countries have more stringent
standards than don't forget to speak
into them yes
uh
all i can say to that is that when you
look at what other countries have done
in terms of their standards they're much
more stringent than ours
and there there was science there that
they actually have science backing up
their standards
we have no science backing up our
standards
and that's why the court case ruled the
way they did
because they were trying to say no those
standards we set back in 1996 is still
okay today in 1996
i think we had 2g
if if that
now we have 5g and no one's no one's
looking at what the impact of that is
and and and the courts i think ruled in
the correct manner that they did
thank you
okay representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
aside from the health aspects
establishing the distance of 500 meters
which
i believe is highest priority did the
committee
study or run across any other
information involving how
5g would affect any operational aspects
of equipment or any other items uh
people's health not withstanding i'm
just curious if they found any uh if
they found anything in terms of distance
optimum distance and so forth
but yeah there are certain distances
that we
but the main one is this the sighting of
tennis distance
uh
we also looked at uh
the environment in general
what it's doing to the bees what it's
doing to to to plants and all that
uh but we did we didn't address that in
this we're trying to take one step here
and really just try to get the setbacks
and by the way that setback we're not
going to disturb any of the antennas
that exist today that that that'd be a
possible thing to do we're saying let's
just look forward
and have a have a rule that says
uh that says 1640 feet
um
and which which
in just basically residential areas by
the way
in residential areas as well as the
schools and all that that may not be in
a residential area so we we're trying to
be reasonable here
you know if there's a lot of land near
the road you see a lot of cell towers
along the highways
that usually there's not many homes
there it still can be they can still be
siding
cell towers in those areas thank you
follow up
thank you mr and thank you for the
follow-up so um
just curious in view of the recent
information that's just come out on the
from from the faa
at any time did anyone from the
manchester airport come to your
committee and discuss uh
issues with uh you know distance to the
airport and how it might affect uh its
operations no no i think that's just
that's really breaking news the last
couple of weeks
uh obviously the
the faa and the aerospace
folks
have been looking at this
before
people think that 5g has been deployed a
lot it hasn't been fired it's it's
getting there it hasn't been fully
deployed
but then they started to see that
there's sensitivity to the instruments
from 5g
now there are a lot of tile towers near
current airports that are 2g 3g 4g
and that was never an issue
why why is it an issue now
because i think the power densities are
a lot higher
we're into millimeter waves and we're
just finding out
how it's impacting
uh instruments but
impacting instruments
what's it doing to humans
so
thank you representative jackie kelly
pitts
i have
one question um
the faa itself is conflicted right now
about how many seconds
it they need to have uh these ins this
cell tower deactivated
my question is has the case
from the district court ever been
appealed
and
is it going to be appealed as far as you
know
at this point it hasn't been appealed
thank you and i i would really suggest
that you read this piece that and
there's two two
this piece and this piece gives you the
whole history this one
and this one tells you what happened
with the with the court case in detail
in detail and it gives you what the next
step is going to be in the court case i
wasn't able to read it i was going to
read it thank you
thank you representative nutter is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question it actually is
from a colleague who couldn't be here
regarding the 1.5 million dollars over
three years to implement a very tiny
database including hiring two
database personnel plus a 500 000 a year
support contract
couldn't this be built and secured with
something like google farms forms in a
few days
again
my bill didn't specify that it that was
the fiscal note
that if we read it i can't remember if
it was the um
well we we recommended that the hhs run
this database because they do run it
other data i did talk to them a while
back
we never talked about the course the
cost
i think they went to the department of
energy
i don't know why the department of
energy but they went to the department
of energy
i i think they should have gone to the
to environment ep the department of
environmental service in our state
but
with that said we don't agree with that
fiscal not at all
there this can be done
i mean this is a simple database
and and it's not we're not asking hhs to
to actually manipulate the data we're
just saying how's it in your your area
and
and you know we will make sure that the
data integrity is there
and then we're opening it up to
researchers
to then
access that data and and do whatever
analysis they want to do
but basically what what we talked about
in committee was
that trying to identify hot spots in the
state where
we're
using
human feedback as
as one of the indications that people
who are feeling sensitive to this
frequencies
one of the things we had talked about
was actually doing testing because
nobody tests
nobody tests on an ongoing basis whether
even meeting current
if we're even meeting current levels of
of
of radiation exposure right now
but so we we again we could have put a
whole peripheral a whole bunch of things
up forth to the committee to consider
but we tried to narrow it down let's
take a step at a time thank you
follow up follow up
thank you um same colleague who couldn't
be here today um said that he's looked
at a lot of studies and most of the
studies he's he's seen has referenced
are about
cell phone radiation and not cell tower
radiation
i my question is what uh what's the
difference between the two
well your phone has like uh six antennas
in it
your phone has six antennas in there
one for your gps one for your you know
for your phone you know there's there's
a whole bunch of things that's a whole
other issue we looked at
again we chose
not to
to
bring that forth we talked about having
warnings
you know on a whole whole variety of
things that we we thought that
would help the situation
but we didn't think it was practical for
just new hampshire to handle on its own
it's really a federal issue
now one can argue that what we're
talking about here is a federal issue
but we're saying okay new hampshire
let's be bold let's start with the south
to cell towers
and uh
and let's move move forward and coming
up because there are communities and i
meant to say this let me say this real
quick
there are communities that are coming
about ordinances in terms of this
the only problem with the ordinances
some are and we're going to hear from
senator mccarty she did that in bedford
uh and there's others here that are
going to speak about other ordinances
the problem with ordinances is that
we're relying on the towns to do the
battle
and we don't i think the state has to
help them out
and give some voice to the for these
communities because let me tell you this
battle is going on
everywhere everywhere
and
yes and i i'd say no let's not look at
the aesthetics let's not look at that
what's the real issue here the real
issue is
is exposure over exposure and again like
i said earlier none of you would like it
if someone put a cell tower in your
backyard
you have one
that's why you glow so much
just joking
uh representative plett is recognized
for a question
yes thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question
5g
is new to telecom but it isn't no uh the
fcc auctioned that frequency for use in
telecom what was it used for before and
did it cause a concern then
well i have people behind me that would
probably answer that better than i can
um
but i think those
those auctions were for
they knew because 5g is a concept first
off and it's a marketing issue okay
every every telecom company
has a different strategy for rolling out
its 5g
and someone talked about small cell
towers
and that's they needed millimeter waves
which are far further up the
electromagnetic spectrum
and so but they're way ahead even if
they were auctioned off five six years
ago they wanted to to to get get those
for the next generation but but you
would say well gee was why didn't
anybody test this want anybody to see if
there's any any health issues around
that
and that's basically where we're at
right now
so
i'm not sure if there were other uses
for the 5g uh it's really the millimeter
waves again if you know they're like you
guys are science tech the electron
explains from
you know for 80 frequency waves now
we're getting further up the
spectrum
thank you thank you representative
harrington is recognized for a question
yeah thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um referring to
page three of the bill where you talk
about the radiation exposure registry
it this is kind of really wide open i
mean
radiation comes from a lot of places for
example if you share your bed with
someone you're going to get a lot more
radiation than if you sleep alone
how is this going to be limited to
wireless radiation exposure where
there's so many other possible sources
of radiation that could come from
anywhere
well i agree this this is broader than
just the cell towers
this thing
i mean there are people are turning and
turning off their routers
because
they're feeling the routers okay in
their house
uh
or
you know and we stayed away from smart
meters
a lot of people and believe me since
i've been involved in this i get i get
emails and mails
every day
from people why are we doing something
with uh smart meters
and uh i know there was a bill a couple
of years ago on smart meters but it was
it was not
properly uh presented or
thought through
because there are again there's three
levels of smart meters
you know one is
the truck goes by
it goes on
there's one that pulses maybe a couple a
couple times an hour and then there's
the others that pulse continuously
and those are the ones we should be
concerned about the ones that that pulse
continuously
so
thank you thank you can i follow up mr
chairman follow up uh yeah you would
mention the uh this fee was going to be
embedded in the cost would you because
that is one thing that i really don't
like hidden fees that people don't know
what they're paying for and if there's
going to be a fee maybe it should be out
there so that everyone knows what
they're paying for would you be amended
to uh willing to amend the bills so that
the fee would actually appear on some of
these telephone bills so they know what
they're paying for
um yes but i would i would venture to
say first off
the costs i think are inflated
when you take a lower cost because i
think the state can do it a lot cheaper
than this but whatever the cost all
right right but but it's going to be so
miniscule
when you spread it across the number of
cell phone users or pad people with pads
or whatever
uh end users
uh
and then we're we're saying well why
don't we do it this way like we do with
the oil companies
as one example is charge it at the
wholesale they would be the you know
verizon att whatever
uh level
and it's again the ongoing cost is on
even at the high end it's 230 000 with
two people but i don't think they need
two people to maintain this
so
um yeah i would yes sure if you want to
representative flozier is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
representative brahmi on page page three
in regards to radiation exposure
registry it looks like it's up to the
residents my question is
right now is there any documentation
ordinance regulations
that
gives the
documentation for the frequency power
density dense intensity over time
already
that they are they emit
not
not that we're aware of there could be
a follow-up
follow-up thank you
it's going to be hard for me to see
with this bill going through
if that doesn't exist
what
do they use those
that information against
well what is what is known though is
every every every antenna is is
registered
so we know what the antennas are there's
a you can look it up
uh so all of a sudden we because you
gotta remember part of the problem part
of the problem is it's one thing to have
one antenna what we we're just learning
about is how these antennas interact
with each other
so
that
so you could be in a neighborhood that
has a lot of antennas
and
you know we're not picking on anyone
we're just trying to say listen
there seems to be a lot of sensitivity
to the energy coming out of these
antennas
i mean
just just to be able to start
documenting this we have to start
somewhere
to try to start documenting then first
then we said well why don't we why don't
we work with there is an icd code for
radio sensitivity
uh
but not everybody and there are people
who are actually uh coded that way in
their medical records
and we can we can talk more about that
at some other time if you'd like so it
isn't like it's not recognized in the
healthcare arena it is
okay
thank you okay representative bernardi
is recognized for a question
thank you thank you chairman
and thank you uh mr brahmi um
my question focuses in on the
meter limitation
uh it does not appear to be tied to any
power limitation or power density
uh from these antennas so
as an example
light it can be seen for a certain
distance
if you cranked up the power you could
probably see it for a much greater
distance but you've just limited this to
500 meters
what
if we're concerned with exposure we're
concerned with a certain amount of
energy that's being uh distributed so
how how is a 500 meter limit controlling
this because what happens to these it's
yeah you're all right you're right power
density is the key thing
um
and you know we talked about in the
committee you know wow how do we do this
i mean
they cause they can manipulate the power
power density different times of the day
whatever you know
uh
so we thought the easiest thing to do
is to is just to put a
limit now there are some science studies
that will be talked about by um
professor chamberlain in a minute that
would he could probably do a better job
at answering your question if you don't
mind
okay but fine yeah and again it's not
the 500 meters isn't just we didn't pick
it out of the air
no no pun intended
but
there's science behind that
thank you follow up
all set okay
representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question and i i do i'll do a
follow-up question based on
representative
bernardi's question so
my question would be
in reference to the 500 meter
would there be or could there be an
associated
power limit
associated with that distance
if if regulations were
created and produced because um
i don't know how much power is created
to to transmit 5g but is there is is it
possible to combine the two in in either
your bill or some other regulation that
would uh set this record straight
for you before you answer representative
abrami i need to apologize to the
members of the committee we have a rule
that says no member shall ask more than
two questions of a given witness
and i just violated that rule by
representative thomas to ask a third
question so i apologize for the to the
committee i won't let that happen again
i apologize chair i i interpret that
mean two separate questions but thank
you
well
to answer your question that wasn't
asked
uh
that
we would we would welcome that
discussion with you
uh to try to look at it because you
gotta remember on a tower there's
multiple antennas
i mean there's you've seen a tower with
one antenna there's usually you know 15
20 and 10 is all you know pointing in
different directions and all that and
then you gotta you gotta look at the the
uh the cumulative effect of all of this
uh is the real issue
okay thank you uh representative abrami
for that thorough introduction to house
bill 1644.
before i call the next
witness
there were a couple of operational
issues i neglected to mention earlier i
just wanted to point out a couple of
things
representative samsich and
representative lewicki are not here
today because both of them are in the
senate energy hearing
at 10 o'clock so i'll be leaving shortly
before 10 and handing the gavel over to
my vice chair
right now i would like to call to the
witness table
senator denise riccardi to testify on
this bill and senator i hope three
minutes will be sufficient for you well
with the constraints i do want to
preface that any science that i speak to
or any published document
the links have been provided for you in
my testimony so i will not refer to them
and i'm going to speak very quickly
thank you we appreciate that so um good
morning thank you mr chair members of
the committee for allowing me to testify
and thank you esteemed colleagues for
your work on this critical bill for the
record my name is denise ricciardi i'm
the senator for district 9.
i need to tell you first my personal
experience so several years ago i in the
town of bedford where i live
they were going to put a cell phone
tower in my backyard and the backyard of
our elementary school and i thought oh
that's kind of ugly i wonder if it's
dangerous
and that's how my journey began it was a
three year battle and i've been to
washington and i have educated myself i
have a commission
so that's
why
i am here today also i worked very
tenaciously in bedford to have a
telecommunications committee and write
ordinances and do everything i could to
so as i was investigating the cell tower
radiation issue i discovered that while
information is presented by companies
that make it seem like cell tower
radiation is safe in fact there are no
safety assurances when it comes to this
radiation while wireless companies put
forward federal agency statements as
supporting their stance a deeper look
reveals that these agencies have not
looked at all the science nor have they
concluded safety is assured furthermore
and most importantly the federal
agencies that the public assumes are
ensuring our health and safety are in
fact not ensuring safety long story
short there is no u.s health and safety
agency that is studying cell tower
radiation and reviewing all of the
research on which which to ensure i am
technology i do not want us going
backwards what i do want is safe
sustainable responsible technology this
bill is a public health and safety
measure to support towns across the
state so that cellular networks are more
responsibly placed i'm not suggesting we
remove this technology i really need to
emphasize this we just need to do it
safer and smarter i'd like to share with
you some facts that i learned in hopes
all of you can make an educated decision
the fcc cell tower radiation safety
limits do not ensure safety their
25-year old limits that were set in
1996.
this
state rules that say that the only way
this radiation can harm us is if it
creates heat please refer to appendix d
of the majority report in the commission
for ample science showing you that you
don't need heat to cause harm
wireless radiation has been found in
peer-reviewed published science to cause
serious damage at not heating levels the
fcc and the industry promote reports
from the fda making it seem like the fda
believes cell phone tower radiation to
be safe this is inaccurate first the fda
has never done a formal review of all
the independent science secondly the fda
has no authority when it comes to cell
towers cell radiation antennas and such
they have not reviewed the full body of
research on cell tower radiation
um in fact the fda has
what they have done is put out a now a
now outdated literature review
only on the phones not on anything else
if you actually read this report you
will see it is not about the towers that
create the non-stop radiation exposures
day and night but the the cell phones
and and it's it's all it's all together
um but several health organizations have
filed a petition with the fda and the
hhs to declare
cell phone tower radiation and eminent
hazard this month the pittsburgh law
review published an article stating and
i quote the fcc and fda have failed in
their obligation to prescribe safe rfr
guidelines produced from wireless
communication devices to protect the
public health and safety
consider this
when i wrote as a member of the new
hampshire commission to the fda with
questions about specific questions about
the health effects of cell tower
radiation the fda did not adequately
respond i wrote back again with a list
of questions and i said please answer
them point by point please do not use a
paragraph that you have on your website
i actually had to enlist our
u.s senator senator shaheen's office and
they tried
they would not answer the fda wrote back
a short email without addressing any of
the questions
um
they didn't even
there and there is an email chain of
this in the new hampshire commission
report that you can refer to senator uh
i've given you some latitude you're well
over five minutes oh i'm sorry could you
uh wrap up fairly quickly thank you okay
i'm very sorry thank you for that um
well
all right there's if you have the
testimony in front of you there there is
a lot there and there is science and
links
but what i want to say to you is we just
have to ask ourselves
do we want this in front of our homes
it's a public safety issue and you know
governor sununu's done such a great job
for our our state and one thing he was
quoted and saying
in washington
the washington examiner the role of
government comes down to health and
safety so i want to use those words
as you educate yourself and you move
forward i truly appreciate the extra
time and really wish i could have
finished but i understand i sit you know
in the same seat you do thank you
senator that was an excellent uh
closing statement and uh i'll now find
out if the committee has any questions
uh representative mcgee is recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator riccardi for uh your testimony
um i you served on this uh 5g committee
and my question is when we had a 5g bill
last year
there was discussion around the fact
that 5g seems to be a technology where
they're looking for more locations
than they've had in the past that there
are going to be
existing polls that would be retrofitted
so that there are
it's a it's sort of a denser network in
other words there's more to it at least
that was my understanding so i wondered
if you could speak about not just um you
know the larger antennas but whether or
not they're going to be leveraging
existing poles that might be integrated
in our neighborhoods for example because
i was curious about that well the answer
would be yes as a matter of fact i
started a wire and polls committee in
bedford to address this
and
that means no one can come in without
going before this committee and that and
it doesn't single out the industry it
covers the board for anything that goes
on a poll
um the way it and i'm going to let the
scientists speak better so forgive me
this is just going to be me with my
knowledge um
5g is millimeter waves and 5g doesn't
work alone it has to be piggybacked with
3 or 4g
or it won't work it also doesn't work if
it's too high and it also doesn't work
if it's too far apart
so what they are wanting to do is to put
them in front of every other home and
force us to live in a soup of microwave
radiation
and a lot of what's going on um is they
want the
cars that can drive themselves and they
put them along our highways or they also
want to be able so people can stream
movies while they're driving well or
passengers
so at the end of the day
um
we do need the technology for our phones
and
computers but i ask you do we need to
stream movies in the car
thank you
okay are there any uh representative
bernardi is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um
so
it's clear the food and drug
administration does not have
any authority to answer your health and
safety questions they're i've worked in
the industry for 40 years their their
metric is food
drugs and medical devices so you're
you're not going to get an answer from
them however
the fcc when you have discussed things
with them i believe
they have authority in this area did
they give you any response
no
thank you
representative harrington is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman i
thank you for taking my question
obviously we've had a lot of discussion
we're going to have more discussion on
the harmful effects of 5g
can you maybe since you were on this
commission tell us what's the downside
of not having 5z i mean my cell phone
works quite well right now and i can put
on you know streaming movies at home and
so forth and i really don't want to do
them while i'm driving but uh what's
what are we losing if uh is is there any
real big pressing need to have 5g
i do not believe so i believe you know
i'm going to say something i'm probably
going to get in trouble for this but
it's always about the money you know
when are we going to make it about
people and health and do our job and
protect the people
you can have technology without it being
that it's driven to do the automated
cars it's driven for those reasons and i
also want to add that um the higher a
tower
the less
dangerous it is to you
this uh rollout if you will where
they're going to put the telephone poles
in front of homes
is going to be
right at your level of your home
which makes it even more dangerous again
i'm going to let the scientists and
doctors speak to that i don't i i know
the information but not having that
credential i prefer not to
thank you senator i just want to
verify as someone who served on the 5g
commission are all the source studies
that the commission used to compile its
information available to the general
public yes
our commission is on the uh website for
the at the state house and everything is
there the full report the the links
the presenters the people who came and
spoke to us um it's all there
great thank you very much and we really
appreciate you being here to testify to
our committee here this morning thank
you for being here thank you and i'm
taking off for education so i apologize
okay good luck there
all right
okay so we're gonna move on now
and uh i'm gonna call
and i'm not sure
if the gentleman's name
came out correctly it looks like his pen
failed halfway through writing his name
oh senator gray okay um yes senator gray
you can go next
thank you we both want to get to that
energy committee
i am
senator james gray i represent senate
district six
i was
also on the committee
in fact 10 pages of that report that
you've got in front of you
if you look at it my name's right at the
some of the information you've received
today
talks about all of the issues that were
talked about in that committee this
bill that's in front of you talks about
antennas and talks about
effects on individuals and whether
electro
magnetic
hypersensitivity is the term that they
use
so let's concentrate on on the two
things the antennas the build the way it
is right now says placement of i believe
is the word they use
um does i've just learned here that that
does not mean that i can't have an
existing one there
but doesn't mean that i can replace an
old one doesn't mean
but
it's
.31
miles
so that if i want to put
an antenna somewhere
i have to have a clear space that has a
diameter of
6.62 miles
look at nashua look at manchester look
at whatever and when we're looking at
this 5g stuff
that
the signals the radiation that are
emitted by those systems are smaller
and
effectively they're they're trying to
preempt it
but i want to concentrate on the
electromagnetic hypersensitivity
what we would do to find out whether or
not that is a real thing or a bad thing
i will agree that the symptoms are real
the people are suffering from various
things but is it caused remember
causation
and correlation okay
is a is a big thing okay so we went to
the world health organization
and they said a number of studies have
been conducted where ehs individuals was
exposed to emf
similar to those that were attributed to
the causes their symptoms
they did a double-blind study
okay
and several of these
and they found that there was no link
no causation there was correlation
not
if while you're debating this first
thing you need to do is either expand
the bill
to all those other things that they're
talking about
or
concentrate just on what the bill says
and what the bill says right now
5g is out you're not going to have a 5g
system
is there a smoking gun no there's no
smoking gun
the committee
has
not considered
some of this information because it
doesn't meet
their
criteria
okay we're going to hear from
the university system i shouldn't say
we're going to hear from a professor not
from the university system
we're going to hear from lots of
different people
questions
representative is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question senator and
i apologize for stepping out i have a
meeting at 10 and that clock up there is
five minutes fast
um so i missed part of what you had to
say and i really wanted to hear it so
could you please email it to us
um
i didn't uh write it down ahead of time
so it would be difficult for me to do
that
they just told me i can roll back the
tape and watch it so hey
excellent
representative harrington is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question uh i'm referring
to page four of the uh
committee rep of the commission report
specifically it says why does the
insurance industry recognize wireless
radiation as a leading risk and has
placed exclusions in their policies not
covering damages by the pathological
properties of electromagnetic radiation
can you elaborate on that a little bit
of regard to the i mean when somebody
insurance company when they come out in
a statement it kind of impresses me
because they're talking about their
money i can when people talk about their
money i can only offer you my opinion
my opinion in looking at the industry as
a whole if they can exclude it they will
okay so
is it possible that 10 years from now 15
years and from now 100 years from now we
will identify something that was caused
by
well they don't know so they put in an
exclusion
okay and the follow-up mr jimin follow
up go ahead so basically what i think
i'm hearing from you senator is that
and i tend to agree with your assessment
but if this bill were to pass as written
it would effectively say we're not
having 3g unless you happen to be in
some place in northern 5g
someplace in
coast county maybe in the middle of
nowhere for three customers
i'm being a little facetious there okay
representative kelly piss recognized for
a question
the federal government is getting ready
to uh or has already
uh
appropriated money
for rollout of 5g doing for
broadband
do we know
what the
if they're specifically when they're
putting this out if it's for 5g or if
it's for the lesser do we do we know
that
i think that that goes beyond the scope
of the bill quite a bit but the rollout
of broadband
normally is
either via telephone lines
uh cable lines
or in some cases during you know via
cell
uh communications
so it could be a mix of any of those
technologies exciting i
apologize i forgot the satellites that
we can also
do it by satellites
so you know for the questions senator
greg thank you so much for an excellent
presentation
yes
uh there's a mr ken chamberlin
to speak next please hello
i'm here representing the university
system of new hampshire i served on the
commission
oh yeah i'm just going to hand these out
first
i'm kent chamberlain
i served on the commission and as
professor
doctor
i'll get it right yet
as representative abrami mentioned uh i
was chair of the department of
electrical and computer engineering at
the time that i served on the commission
i've worked for quite a few 25 over 25
sponsored research programs outside of
the university i've worked for industry
and government agencies like the federal
aviation administration
so if anything my bias has been for
technology
i'd like to point out that my purpose
here in speaking i had prepared a much
larger presentation as you can see from
the number of slides i understand that i
don't have time right now
to give my entire presentation but i do
ask for a bit of latitude so that i can
go through the science and i know that
that's what you want to hear today
so um
the fundamental or if yeah fundamental
question that needs to be addressed is
why the new hampshire state commission
picked a setback distance of 500 meters
which is
1640 feet
to begin it's important to note that
there is no perfect answer to this
question because of the the difficulty
in identifying what a safe level of
exposure is
it's also recognized that what is safe
for one person might not be safe for
another
that people who are electrosensitive can
experience symptoms of radiation
exposure at distances greater than 1 640
feet
which means that the proposed setback
may not ensure a reasonable exposure
level for the electrosensitive
population
electrosensitivity is real and it's
recognized with the americans for
disabilities act and medicare
different people have different
sensitivities to radiation exposure just
as they have different sensitivities to
sun exposure foods
such as peanuts and and bee stings
i mean my wife can go out in the sun for
uh for all day practically and and not
get burned i can go out for half an hour
and i get burned and it's the same thing
with electrosensitivity
so there are indications that the number
of people with electrosensitivity will
be increasing over time because the
background levels of radiation that
we're all experienced exposed to
that's rising as you every time you add
a new facility a new antenna your
background level of radiation just like
smog as you increase the levels of smog
the incidence of diseases associated
with smog increase the same thing is
true for background radiation
so a goal of the commission in
establishing a setback was to provide
reasonable protections for the majority
of people while not impeding the use of
wireless communication
when using their own wireless devices
citizens can maintain control of how
much radiation exposure they receive
those wireless devices include their own
cell phones cordless phones wireless
appliances such as printers and baby
monitors and people have the option of
turning these devices off if they do not
wish to be exposed
however they are not able to turn off a
nearby cell tower if they want to reduce
their radiation exposure one minute
please
uh
i'm not going to
touch anything
so
i asked for latitude
you are but you're wasting time by
explaining so keep on going
all right fair enough
so we're going to look at the reasonable
determinant i'm i'll go right into it
but it's not going to be one minute so
if you i mean you're wasting another 30
seconds so please continue fair enough
one approach is to look at the adverse
effects as a function of distance people
live from a cell tower transmitter by
tracking adverse health effects and
determining how they relate to the
distance people live from cell towers
you can get a sense of where the
exposure risk becomes reasonable there
have been at least 10 studies that have
done this and i will be referencing one
of them in the next few slides you have
those in front of you
using these epidemiological studies was
one approach that we use to determine a
setback distance
and i will go right to that one
i'm going to be talking only about that
one study that's in front of you
there have been at least 10 studies
though that have looked at these adverse
health effects and eight of the ten
found the
exposure and identified the 500 meters
that i'm going to be talking about now
so one
what you're looking at in front of you
right now is a study from brazil and the
reason i'm using it is because it
demonstrates so clearly the relationship
that we're trying to find and that is
how far at what distance do you no
longer experiencing severe or
significant adverse health effects so
one important aspect of the brazilian
study is that took place between 1996
and 2006 and the reason this is
important is because a lot of people
didn't have cell phones in brazil at
this time this is a question that was
asked earlier is what is the effect of
the cell tower what is the effect of
your own cell tower
or nearby cell tower
so
after about five years after the study
only 28 of the people in the region had
cell phones so what the study that
you're looking at right now is basically
only the effects of living near a cell
tower and not your own
devices
what's important also in this study is
they looked at a large number of people
over 7 000 deaths
for people living near over 800 cell
towers
and these of course is a large number of
people give you statistical significance
so we have confidence in the results
you're looking at the at the chart so
the takeaway from that study and i'm
going quickly as i can here
sum it up please it's slide seven so the
plot you see in the handout shows the
death rate from cancer as a function the
distance people live from a cell tower
the red trace is for the population in
general the fact that that red and the
blue trace is for the population in
general and the red traces for the
people in the study as you look at that
plot you can see that the incidence rate
of cancer declines for people living
away from the cell tower
and as you get farther far enough away
of course the incidence of cell of
cancer
goes to the same
incidence rate as for the population in
general
but if you look at 500 meters you can
say yes there is a declining cancer rate
a significant decline that's where you
tend to have a break point in the slope
of that that curve but that is what we
identified as being a safe law or a not
a safe as a reasonable setback distance
force for mr chamberlain he's your time
has expired uh thank you for testimony
i've given you twice as much time as as
what was originally reported i
appreciate it thank you very much thank
you uh may i remind the um before i go
into questions may i remind anyone here
if you have written testimony it is far
quicker to just summarize the bullet
points on your written testimony than to
read them just pass it to our committee
and we can read it later this will save
time and get right to the point thank
you very much anybody have questions
here from committee
represent representative harrington you
recognize for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
this kind of follow-up from the previous
discussions there you you put out i'm
looking at your chart with the 500
meters being sort of the break point
where the curve starts to level off
um
and there is not a
huge degree of savings or health factors
when you go beyond that distance but
based on what we've talked about before
would you agree or maybe you know more
about 5g than i do
which you probably do
uh could it is it even possible to
implement 5g given that
500 meters and you know the population
density of new hampshire is it's not new
york city but there's not a hell of a
lot of places where there's no one
around for 500 meters you know you raise
a good point the reason we went with 5g
towers as well is that there is no real
defined 5g
5g can use the same frequencies and
oftentimes does use the same frequencies
as are used for 3g and 4g
so in other words they could take one of
these small towers the small cells that
you've heard about perhaps the one
you're referring to and put in a
transmitter that transmits to the same
frequencies as today so we felt that we
didn't want to have those same signals
being radiated from an even even closer
distance so that's why we included the
5g towers in the setback now later on
perhaps there can be other rules that
can be put put in place but right now we
didn't feel that was the case we wanted
to get something in place to protect the
public
follow-up mr chairman one follow-up go
ahead quick so just to get
down to the point here
do you agree that the 500 meter setback
would basically eliminate the
implementation of 5g technology in new
hampshire
no because there is no 5d defined 5g
technology 5g can use the same
frequencies they can call it 5g uses the
same frequencies we have now and it
works just fine
so it doesn't prohibit it it prohibits
it from using maybe some of the higher
frequencies that attenuate more rapidly
with propagation but no you can have 5g
chair recognizes representative kelly
page for a question
thank you professor i want to pretend
i'm in class now do we have any
uh
data on how much radiation each of us is
exposed to every day
and how much more
this new technology
would add to it
it's from the technology we're using now
so do you have any of that
hard data
yeah we do there are studies that are
making measurements in various cities
and the results are as i suggested
earlier is that you look at your
background levels of radiation and
they're steadily going up
just as if you have and i mentioned this
is uh earlier that if you have air
pollution is that increases the the
incidence of asthma cases increases also
so yes we have definitive data that that
shows that the background levels of
radiation from all of electronics from
all radiation sources is increasing and
there's actually been correlations done
on with correlations on the
level of radiation of background level
radiation and health and it is negative
correlation so the more radiation you
have the more likely people are to be
sick because it does suppress and we
have data that show that exposure
radiation depresses your immune system
follow-up go ahead
my follow-up would be
is this new technology that they purport
to bring on
my understanding is yes that if you look
at cities and this has been a study by a
doctor marga
havas
that
if you go to cities that have 5g their
level their background level of
radiation is significantly statistically
significantly higher yes
see no c no further questions uh thank
you mr chamberlain excellent
next up is uh
mr michael roberts from dhhs
good morning members of the committee
for the record my name is michelle
roberge and i am the administrator of
the bureau of public health health
protection within the new hampshire
department of health and human services
division of public health services i
want to thank the committee for the
opportunity to speak today regarding hb
1644.
as written the department does have
concerns with the registry component of
this proposed legislation as noted in
the department's fiscal note and written
the legislative language requires the
department to create an online radiation
exposure registry and to provide
information to the public regarding how
the self-reported information will be
used
in consultation with the department of
energy the department of health and
human services will establish fees to
fund the cost of establishing and
maintaining and advertising the registry
the proposed legislation would require
operators of wireless antennas
in the state to pay fees established to
support the registry
in order to implement this portion of
the bill the department would need to
secure a software vendor through a
competitive bid process to obtain a data
system for storing the required data
an unknown factor that has an impact on
cost is whether the department can
purchase an off-the-shelf product or
will implementation of this
project require a custom design build
and i'd like to just note that the
department can't use a google system
because we are hipaa compliant agency
and so we need to make sure we maintain
that those security measures
we did provide a fiscal note the fiscal
note also estimates the cost with again
developing a vendor contract
establishing data and business system
requirements purchasing or creating a
data system software licenses and
required security provisions to be
approximately 750 000
in addition the department estimates
ongoing costs for maintenance of the
system to be 50 000 a year
it's also anticipated that we would
require two additional staff to carry
out the work related again to data
management security and privacy
requirements associated with the
proposed legislation and those costs are
included in the fiscal note
i'd also like to just note that the
department has concerns with the term
biologic
in in the bill language it ref as its
reference to symptoms as the term is
unclear and open to interpretation it's
not clear if this is a reference to
medical symptoms or psychiatric symptoms
or both the department has concerns
related to the proposed registry and
compliance with hipaa requirements and
data validation as the proposed registry
is a self-report registry it would be
difficult for the department to us
to
validate the data for accuracy
[Music]
as written the proposed fees to support
the registry are to be established by
the department of energy and
consultation with the department of
health and human services and are to be
paid by the owners of the wireless
antennas or tower towers the the
department does have concerns um that
the provo that the proposed fees
potentially could not be collected or
the wireless companies may not agree to
pay the fees and then there is no
appropriation
for this registry
for the department and again also
written there is no rule-making
authority in the language either to
establish these fees or this collection
system and again no appropriation
please sum up please yep so due to these
concerns noted above and as discussed
with the sponsor of the bill the
department feels that implementation of
this registry would be more aligned
through an academic institution for
research purposes
um and and that pretty much sums it up
i'm available for questions
thank you very much
uh
chair recognizes representative
harrington for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
when i read this uh radiation exposure
registry section of this bill and i'll
try to make this really quick it looked
to me like it was open to and not being
derogatory but almost any kook in the
country or the state could come up and
say i'm getting exposed to radiation
somehow and i want this reported because
now it's making me sick is this as wide
open as it seems to me where there's
absolutely no limits on whoever
why ever someone wants to be on this
registry
the department understands that this is
a self-reported registry this is
different from any other registries that
the department has whereas providers
medical providers or laboratories would
be reporting information our
understanding of the language in the
bill is that this is a self-report
registry
follow-up mr jim one follow-up so to be
concise then anybody who wanted to say
they're getting exposed to radiation
without any
proof or measuring device or anything
uh to validate that could go into this
registry and say yeah i'm getting sick
because i'm getting exposed to something
my understanding is that this would be
available on the department's website on
their home on our home page and we would
have to advertise that um so yes it
would be open to the public um one of
the concerns that we noted both in our
written testimony and in my testimony
today is the data validation concern
because that is that is problematic for
the department to validate you know
because as as required we're
required to report out okay
i think you've answered my question we
kind of get a line thank you very much
do you recognize this group of kelly
pittsford question i i'm going to follow
up with what i started with the
professor was that we
all here in new hampshire are exposed to
radiation of all different kinds
constantly daily
if i just say i'm exposed to radiation
that would be a true statement
you know fairly near seabrook down by
the nuclear subs you know
um
so how would you quantitate where that
radiation
came from that i was exposed to
yeah that would
would that be a problem that would be a
um a challenge for certainly yes i mean
there's natural radiation as well from
so you know further questions thank you
very much for your testimony appreciate
it
next up i believe is a dr lisa nagi
i hope i pronounced that correctly
thank you my name is cecilia ducette and
i will be reading dr naji's partial
testimony we'll keep it short and i
would like to pass it out to our
from dr lisa naj i am commenting in
support of representative abrami's
legislation house bill 1466
regarding the 500 meter 1 640 foot
installation distance for cell towers
and transmitters i have a number of
credentials in the area of
electromagnetic fields or emf exposure
and intolerance
i with dr l dr lynn patrick hosted the
first ever u.s medical conference on
health effects of emfs in 2019
standing in for my mentor dr bill ray
the late dr bill ray
my cv will be emailed to you shortly and
you will see that i attended the
university of pennsylvania and cornell
medical school and in board certified in
emergency medicine i have participated
for over 20 years in hundreds of
meetings at the cdc nih the epa
and i offer my talk at the national
institutes of environmental health
sciences for you to review and you will
have that link in my email
i educate doctors and the public
including interviews on the netflix
series afflicted dr phil the doctors
nightline and more
i have presented in congress and helped
to raise a hundred million dollars for
toxic exposure research for veterans who
became electrically and chemically
sensitive from wartime exposures
i was never taught in medical school
about environmental exposures the
chronic effects of chemicals or
radiofrequency radiation i learned it by
becoming ill myself and slowly
recovering over a 10-year period i then
went on to practice again and i now
advocate for those without a strong
voice
i appreciate your efforts to learn more
about the wireless radiation issue
although i know it is hard for
politicians and the lay public
supposedly not affected by environmental
exposures that they know of
to realize that these radio frequencies
affect us all in all of the cells of our
body at the level of the voltage-gated
calcium channel although we might not be
aware that our phone heating up in our
hand or heating our ear is evidence of
sensitivity to our already sick cells
decreased blood flow to the brain is
clearly proven to be slowed by cell
phones on a pet scanning study published
a decade ago in the journal of cerebral
blood flow
i will skip over a little bit of this
but i do want to say that in december
2021 the massachusetts medical society
adopted
a wireless communications public safety
standards policy statement such that
appropriate agencies must research the
health effects of radio frequency
radiation
and based on their findings adjust
exposure guidelines
so the wheels of acceptance of the
danger of electromagnetic fields are
turning and it is thought that this
particular distance of 1 640 feet
is a reasonable guideline to start with
although
the very sensitive will still need to be
further away from these kinds of
transmitters
we must train doctors first responders
and emergency room personnel that these
conditions are real the patients are not
mentally ill
and respect their demands to avoid
exposure to anything in the environment
in the ambulances in the er or in the
hospitals that make them acutely ill
please start some up please okay
professional training is available
through the emf medical conference and
in your packet you will see a letter
from the director of the conference
libby kelly
so please it is important for citizens
to be able to register harmful exposures
in the database you propose so we can
quantify the harm epidemio
epidemiologically
and further establish informed public
health policy and she welcomes you to
reach out to dr naj directly thank you
thank you very much do i see any
seeing none thank you so much
sorry representative bernardi is uh
recognized for a question
thank you chairman uh thank you doctor
so the mass medical society adopted this
safety standard policy statement has
there been any work that has
come from that about setting
standards no that was just adopted in
december but in your email you will find
a full resolution
and be able to see what they base their
recommendations on
thank you very much for your testimony
well received
i would again advise everyone this is a
very important subject matter please get
right to your bullet points with the
time we have
is short and we appreciate get right to
the point please thank you so much next
on the agenda is
a beth cooley
beth cooley uh
good morning everyone mr chair and
members of the committee my name is beth
cooley and i am the assistant vice
president of state legislative affairs
at ctia
ctia is the trade association for the
wireless communications industry
i'm here today to respectfully testify
in opposition to h.b 1644. the proposed
legislation is flawed for two
fundamental reasons it is both
unwarranted and
unlawful as you know this legislation
came from recommendations from the
majority report of the 5g commission
ctia also had a seat on that commission
i want to start by saying i have a great
deal of respect for representative
abrami and in the work that he was
trying to do and we were all trying to
do us on the commission but
unfortunately the pandemic took hold and
we lost several months
as a result ctia felt the commission
failed to consider it in a balanced
fashion the well-developed reviews of
the science from the u.s and
international health and safety
organizations we indicated as much as a
signatory to the minority report which
senator gray referenced
now i submitted somewhat lengthy
testimony so of course i want to be
respectful of your time and i just want
to make two points
first this legislation is based on the
unsupported premise that the federal
communications commission the fcc that
their regulated telecommunication
equipment presents a quote significant
public risk that is what the legislation
says
as detailed thoroughly in my written
testimony the consensus of the u.s and
international scientific community
including the world health organization
and the american cancer society is that
there are no known adverse health risks
from the levels of rf energy emitted at
the frequencies used by wireless devices
including cell phones and facilities
including small cells
indeed when setting the limits for rf
emissions of wireless devices the fcc
intentionally provided a significant
safety margin 50 times below the
threshold at which adverse effects were
observed in laboratory animals
second this legislation is also unlawful
and that express preemption bars state
and local antenna regulations based on
rf safety
every court since 2005 that has
addressed state and local efforts to
regulate rf emissions from fcc regulated
telecommunications equipment has held
that federal law either expressly and or
impliedly preempts state regulation
based on challenges to the safety of
wireless equipment
specifically in the federal
communications act section 332 there is
language in there that provides in part
no state or local government may
regulate the placement construction and
modification of personal wireless
service facilities on the basis of
environmental effects of radio frequency
emissions it is clear that that is what
this legislation is seeking to do
in addition the requirement to limit the
placement of telecommunication
telecommunications antennas to that 500
meters that we talked about would
inevitably result in a moratorium on
wireless deployment this is also
unlawful and violates section 253-a of
the federal communications act
so in closing the flawed science and
preemption notwithstanding which
candidly are insurmountable
this bill is actually in conflict of
what new hampshire residents report that
they actually want
a poll conducted by harris poll in
november 2020 showed nearly all voters
and 89 percent said it was very
important to have reliable high-speed
internet connectivity during the
pandemic
and nearly 80 percent supported mobile
wireless upgrades in their communities
mentioning factors like increased
accessibility connectivity and speed
the coven 19 pandemic has placed a white
hot spotlight on the need for
connectivity in closing the digital
divide of which wireless plays a huge
role
legislation like this h.b 1644 would
completely foreclose this option
for these reasons we respectfully
request this bill be rejected thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
uh representative plett recognized for a
question yes i'm the clerk would you
please tell me what ctia stands for
when we were originally formed in the
80s it was the cellular
telecommunications internet association
now we are ctia everything wireless
our website is ctia.org if you'd like
more information so some of your
communications what cellular
representative mckee recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you for your testimony um my question is
you mentioned that
there's a federal law prohibiting
states and localities from having input
so there's a you know
super session
superseding
authority which is true on many of the
infrastructure projects that they try to
limit the ability of
of local areas to you know come up with
nimby or whatever
um can you tell me when that went into
effect like how long that has been in
place the federal communications act was
enacted in 1996. well i don't
i don't mean the federal communications
act itself but i mean the part that says
that
that that the states can't have any say
on um on the placement of uh for
radiation specifically yeah i believe
that was also 96. i will confirm part of
the original yes yeah
and just i mean i know you all know this
um to be clear that's just on the basis
of rf safety of course local and state
governments have have input in other
yes one follow-up thank you
um and so
since there is this exemption based on
rf
specifically
are there any
have there been any health requirements
met or objectives identified that would
allow them to
be deploying
technology that they understand to be
safe in other words
it seems like there's confusion around
whether there is enough knowledge as to
how much radiation
uh
exposure there is and uh whether that's
changing significantly with 5g and then
you know i mean it all follows from
there
that's a great question thank you
representative mr chair um
so the fcc
in consultation with the fda which is
considered the sister agency and the fta
regularly and all of the science is in
my testimony as well so i won't go study
for a study for it with you um
looks at hundreds and thousands of
peer-reviewed independent analysis and
equipment from telecommunications
providers cannot be deployed until it is
uh approved and uh the fcc requirements
are met
in terms of the safety levels so it
can't just be deployed without being
tested that it is safe um and again that
is why the fcc when they develop their
standards looking at independent both
national and internationally reviewed
peer research they set a safety standard
of 50 times below where they would
observe any adverse effects from
non-ionizing radiation just so we're all
clear we're not talking about radiation
you know from a nuclear power plant for
example this is something called
non-ionizing radiation which is the same
as your your wi-fi hotspot back there
just you know so we're all clear and
singing from the same song sheet
does that help the question it does it
can i just follow up on that particular
point or
i thought it was one question
we'll go to the next representative here
okay
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so if i read your uh
testimony correctly what you're saying
is that the federal law uh prohibits
this bill from going into effect it
would nullify it but we keep talking
about 5g here and i'm looking at the
bill itself and the actual only other
than the radiation exposure registry the
actual thing that actually has anything
being placed into law
is
uh paragraph nine on page three which
says the placement of telecommunication
and tenors
so
i'm reading this to say that any
new telecommunication antenna
could not be placed unless it was at
least uh 500 meters or 1640 feet uh from
residential zone parks playgrounds etc
can you give us what would the effect of
that be let's forget about the federal
law for a second let's just say if this
was enacted what would the effect of
that be on the telecommunications
industry in new hampshire thank you
representative for your question mr
chair
there would be an extreme halt to
wireless deployment whether it's 4g or
5g or beyond and and that is a fact
we've talked a lot about small cells and
millimeter waves and that does provide
5g when you're attaching to a pole for
example 5g can also be deployed in a
different spectrum band on macro towers
as well which you think of are the 200
foot towers that you see alongside the
highway this would have a chilling
effect on investment in the state as
well as connectivity uh for your
constituents
follow-up
one follow-up question so would be safe
to say that
what we're talking about is no new cell
coverage any place in the state that
doesn't have it already i think that
chair recognizes uh representative
flozie for a question
thank you mr chairman and for your
testimony
everybody's referring to this 1996
studies fcc really but that's all been
effects
so the do you know
any
attempts
to
have
other studies done
that involves health concerns that were
not thermal
so i know that in 2020 the fda i have
the numbers right here they looked at
125 animal studies and seven epidemiol
epidemiological studies excuse me and
just last month
moby kids published a
the largest case controls case control
study to date of the relationship
between wireless phone use and the risk
of brain tumors in children adolescents
and young adults and they found no
evidence of a causal association between
wireless phone use and brain tumors in
young people so to answer your question
is yes these studies whether they're
being done
by federal agencies but the federal
agencies look at all of these
peer-reviewed both national and
international
studies that are out there i would i
would also know and i'll get you the
right name the united kingdom
health protection agency independent
advisory group on non-ionizing radiation
and the swedish council for working life
and social re and social research also
agree that the guidelines of the fcc
limits have do not cause health effects
so this isn't we're looking at
everything from australia to the uk and
it's not just thermal to answer your
follow-up go ahead
i thank you
co if this is not available could you
forward to the committee
those links and information sure they're
all linked in my written testimony but
i'm happy to follow up with any
the chair has one quick question
out of
curiosity we talk in terms of
of the 5 meters 500 meters minimum
distance
is there a minimum distance
from which 5g technology would not work
or or you would not get closer to i
should say
i'm not sure that thank you mr chair i'm
not sure i can answer that question
because it's all dependent on the
topography
you know for example um if we're talking
about mountains and hills or are we
going down i mean so this is you know
line of sight when we're talking about
millimeter wave specifically
um it can go as far as a football i've
heard of two football fields but again
it depends on topography it also depends
on the pole that is being used of course
it needs to be structurally sound so
there's a lot of factors to answer that
question so i could not provide you a
blanket answer i apologize on what is
acceptable
okay thank you
go ahead
the question for the chair is that i i
notice
and has been the the policy in the past
that there are members of the public
here who do not
represent any particular
lobbyist interest and i'm wondering if
we could hear from some of them even if
it's on an integrated basis as we're
going into the hour
that's an excellent question and a great
segue into my next speaker who happens
to be
miss laurie
schrierer i guess i can't the spelling
is
hazy and she's representing herself so i
i assume that's a member of the public
i am a resident of new hampshire for 17
years in west milan a rural residential
area
i'm a retired attorney an advocate for
safe technology in keene
and i attended a lot of the commission
meetings and i'm also a volunteer
citizen scientist with the global emf
monitoring project
my interest in health effects of
of um emf started when i was exposed to
magnetic fields in my home
uh there were stray currents coming from
a uh electric pole actually down my well
shaft and so i had a lot of magnetic
fields through my wiring and as a result
of that i believe that i became emf
sensitive and according to the research
and i link one of the documents
the more we are exposed to different
kinds of emf
in electromagnetic fields the more
sensitive we become
so the more we add small cells every few
hundred feet the more all of us are
going to start feeling some effects most
likely over time
and i personally do have symptoms when i
spend more time near cell towers or near
in wireless
environments which is not my home i do
not have wi-fi i use a landline i use an
ethernet computer i keep my cell phone
on
airplane mode as much as possible i have
symptoms of insomnia ringing in both
ears fatigue nosebleeds sometimes in
rashes
when i am more exposed so i personally
have this experience not to the point of
disability so i don't have a diagnosis
but i know my uh
my i know my life i know my experience i
know where i've been exposed i do have a
safe and sound pro 2 meter so i can see
where there are high fields when i'm
spending time somewhere
i got the meter specifically also
upgraded to that meter because i wanted
to have
to be a volunteer with the global emf
monitoring project and i did some
monitoring on main streets
in keene and also in other places where
i was vacationing and just so you know
but a small cell
that i monitored near a nursing home it
was about 150 feet from a nursing home
and it had and sixty six thousand
microwatts per square meter which is
very high a thousand microwatts per
square meter is what the building
biology institute recommends for outdoor
exposure and the elderly as we know are
very vulnerable
also i did some readings by the beach
because i was on vacation it was 89 000
microwatts per square meter from a small
cell tower near the beaches this was not
in new hampshire i will say but this is
what the utilities are doing and the
towns are allowing without intervention
by the state we need the state to take
bold action
in keene i was very involved with
providing information on wireless
impacts and scientific studies and
testified before them when they were
considering their ordinance which they
have passed but initially they uh
instituted more they instituted a
moratorium on 5g because they saw the
science and they they were concerned and
they had the moratorium they said until
the 5g commission report but then after
about five six months they withdrew that
from in part from pressure for the
industry from the industry uh for legal
concerns not knowing um what the best
course was and they um seem to need um
to have more
state backing so they can act boldly um
there are opportunities
okay their ordinance does only express
preferences for not being in residential
areas and for being up to 750 feet from
sensitive areas but again these are only
preferences and they're not requirements
and i urge the state to take some action
on this and as you know from the 5d
report the
emfs are considered a pollutant
a pollutant so when you buy a house real
estate agent technically if there's a
cell tower nearby they should be letting
you know that there is an environmental
hazard condition according to new
hampshire law
in in that vicinity
and this is all in my in my testimony
thank you uh ms uh schreyer did i get
that right yes thank you for your
testimony okay appreciate it we have
seeing none i thank you for your
testimony
and i will now call
on christina matthews of stratford new
hampshire
thank you
good morning my name is christina
matthews i recently moved to new
hampshire from pennsylvania early this
i was diagnosed with ems electromagnetic
sensitivity two years ago
this past december from a team of
doctors at the environmental health
center in dallas texas
i spent five weeks at the center
monday through friday
i saw the team of doctors and had
testing done on me
daily along with receiving intravenous
infusions daily
i was put at high risk
by a cardiologist for aneurysms
along with being diagnosed with
autonomic nervous system dysfunction
where my neurological nervous system was
reversed
i continued bi-weekly treatments when i
got home to pennsylvania where a large
amount of my blood was removed and put
through an ultraviolet light and oxygen
was put into my blood and then sent back
into my body
this is done because my blood does not
get enough oxygen and also it helps to
heal
my organ cells and tissues that have
been damaged
i continue treatments bi-weekly here in
new hampshire
i have been out of work for the past two
years
while receiving no compensation
i was denied disability due to the fact
the us does not recognize microwave
illness as a disability
no insurance company will cover damage
to
health or the environment for microwave
illness
i know this first hand as i was denied
medical coverage for my insurance
company and ranked up over eighty
thousand dollars in medical bills just
for my five weeks at the center in
dallas texas
insurance continues to deny my treatment
costs
i decided to move to new hampshire to
heal
the electrical grid is lower and there
are far less cell phone towers than most
other states
i found a home in a small town called
stratford
i chose this home because there is no
cell towers in the town and the closest
tower is four miles away
i also do not get any cell service at my
home and according to my rf meter there
are no radio frequencies picked up at my
home
for me this is heaven but for many this
can be an inconvenience
understandably so as many people rely on
technology these days
unfortunately with this technology comes
biological effects which are immediate
and measurable
and health effects which can take years
to manifest
this past tuesday there was a meeting at
my town hall
where the stratfor town committee
proposed construction
of four
cell phone towers to be placed
north south east and west coordinates
30 seconds please trying to stop one
cell phone tower from being constructed
is hard enough
but four towers seems almost impossible
to stop
when i heard this noose i got sick to my
stomach
i thought i found the perfect place to
heal
okay well we thank you for your
testimony and uh we wish you the best
with your uh health situation
are there any uh let's uh not ask this
uh
testifier any questions i think that
would be appropriate so let's move on to
our next
presenter
who will be
ken wells of maple street in andover new
hampshire
thank you chairman rose and members of
the science tech and energy committee
for a few minutes of your kind detention
and thank you especially for an
opportunity to testify in support of hb
1644 today for the record i am ken wells
of andover new hampshire as a former
member of this house committee i was
privileged to work with most of you and
also to work with members of
representative abrami's 5g commission in
as a former teacher of physics
electromagnetism and electronic circuit
design and with my experience in
biochemistry and biophysics research the
university of pennsylvania today's topic
is as they say right in my wheelhouse
you've heard a lot of testimony today on
the biological and health effects of
radio frequencies rf
used by today's wireless data and cell
phone systems from people who experience
these effects but you may be skeptical
i too was skeptical of these claims
about high-energy rf because i'd never
experienced them myself nor had i any
reason to look for research done on this
topic
in my testimony today i'm going to go
into somewhat different direction
and i'm going to look only at the
at the the thermal effects which are
much larger
than the non-thermal effects which are
very insidious
now the claim was made earlier today
that there is no evidence of harm from
any rf emissions and i asked myself is
it likely or even possible that high
energy rf at cell phone frequencies can
cause harm
i wish to tell you that millimeter wave
radio frequency radiation can indeed
cause harm and the devices specifically
designed for that harmful purpose have
been successfully built and tested
more than 20 years ago the u.s air force
began development of its so-called
active denial system a directed energy
weapon for crowd control which is used
uses exactly identical radiation to that
used in proposed 5g systems
and i will include the url for a field
demonstration conducted by the national
security policy national defense
university
this report notes such a weapon may be
limited in use in warfare by
international law but that no laws limit
its use domestically presumably against
u.s citizens interesting
the first u.s air force prototype was
about the size of two tractor trailers
and it used three and a quarter
millimeter or 95 gigahertz rf as a crowd
control device whose range was quote
greater than conventional small arms in
testing it could cause quote an
instantaneous burning sensation in one
tenth of a second exposure along with
first and second degree blistering burns
on human subjects for exposures less
than 10 seconds in one case requiring a
two-day hospitalization
the second military prototype was more
compact mounted on a humvee with a large
steerable antenna to aim the beam an
unwieldy concentrated power supply was
required to achieve the desired beam
range of seven football fields with a
single large antenna
but there is another way to steer this a
beam requiring no large concentrated
power supply and that is to use a
so-called phased array of small antennas
spaced a few hundred feet uh apart
the third prototype could be as compact
as the proposed 5g array of small
street-level antennas commercial
developers of 5g are already touting the
system's steerable concentrated beams
there's a feature of this excuse me mr
wells yes you seem to be straying from
the
topic of our
of the bill here i believe the topic of
the job
discussions of the bill under discussion
i will do that thank you because you
have 30 seconds left yes this bill uh is
about the distance between the antennas
and the risk escalates rapidly the
smaller and more densely packed space
these 5g antennas are are placed it's
called densification current deployments
advertise placing an antenna and a
kevlar housing on every street light or
utility pole and the world's largest and
cheapest seller is the notorious huawei
of china why would we help install a
dense antenna system in new hampshire
that can do us harm that's manufactured
by a country that may become a potential
adversary and who has also written the
software presumably so it's hackable
over an internet connection
do we have a simple way to to prevent
this foreseeable danger yes you pass
this legislation to make it impossible
for antennas to be placed more closely
than 500 meters
and uh from our homes our schools our
workplaces and i might add from each
other this would be a good and simple
amendment
okay thank you very much we appreciate
your test testimony today
uh representative platt is recognized
for a question yes thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question how
does a
weapon deliberately designed to harm
relate to what's before us today that's
because it's an rf weapon that uses uh
95 gigahertz millimeter waves exactly
the same as what is proposed for the
high energy rf
okay thank you any uh further questions
for mr wells
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
so
i understand
when the 5g commission was working
together they were not just looking at
health but they were also looking at
security issues is that correct or is
this something separate and distinct
that you
stumbled on
well
the charge of the commission was to look
at the possible health effects of
emerging 5g technology these health
effects could be weaponized and
therefore i think that it is a cyber
security issue because these uh waves
can be used to hurt people
and hurt of course is a health effect
thank you
uh follow-up follow-up another question
that i had wanted to ask prior but i'll
ask it here
is um we're talking about the capacity
or the
um the impact of the
rf at the frequency that it's being
delivered but uh were there also
concerns about the
the um
the constant repetition the constancy of
the emissions i guess is another
question that we haven't really
discussed yes it's going out but it's
going out regularly and maybe the
yes the real difficulty is that the fcc
does not actually uh bench test or field
test they look at the literature
submitted by the manufacturers so it
doesn't have the ability to uh collect
uh time averaged uh power uh densities
uh out in the field and and these uh the
power density of these systems
varies wildly
you know billions of times higher at one
moment than it is a moment later as they
switch on and off and i'm sure you've
seen the television ads for 5g that
point out that it's a steerable beam so
if the beam's not aimed at you it's low
intensity but when it is it's very high
intensity
so um you know i don't think that that
uh the
prevention of these um closely space
antennas will impact
new hampshire residents ability to
connect to the internet or communicate
at all but they will make them safer if
they're farther apart
we have other technologies such as fiber
and
light based li-fi that can do the same
wi-fi
same thing as wi-fi doing does right now
without using rf
representative kelly pitts is recognized
nice to see you again ken good to be
seeing thank you i
am confused which you know i usually am
uh
5g is advertised now and and
people supposedly have it
so what is the difference
between
not in all technical but is there a
difference between the technical the the
5g that we're talking about and the 5g
that people supposedly
are using now
my phone is one step up from an orange
scan and i like it that way
so i i really like to know if you know
do we have it in place now are we just
talking about something that's here or
coming
yes thank you for that question uh as as
other people have testified 5g is a is
an advertising
name of uh of a fifth generation uh
improved new and improved technology uh
there are several different ways of
achieving that what's on sale right now
are the 5g handsets we do not yet have a
a densified array of antennas as
somebody was describing a little while
ago that are a couple hundred feet apart
when you do this you can overlap the
signals from each one of those things so
you get a very very high power uh
signal at
at one particular location and it can be
high enough it would actually reach the
follow-up
i guess i might i might be
asking the wrong person but is that 5g
high-intensity
signal
give better reception to other people or
make it make the system more available
or is it unnecessary
it's not the only technology that can
achieve this purpose
but it it is uh it is both a higher
frequency
more line of sight a more powerful
microwave uh
wave and it's a higher power density and
both of these things yes will give your
your instrument much better coverage
because it saturates even more energy
but it does the same thing to your body
thank you
thank you uh
representative
somebody else had their hand up i
thought
representative oxenam did you have your
oh i didn't see that okay thank you
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you mr wells
uh
right i guess i'd like to understand
uh this whole bit about having
these uh
installations on every other telephone
pole
i live in a rural area but i have
a
fiber optic cable to my house
and i have you know 100
megabytes per second i could probably
even opt for 300 megabytes per second
how does this compare
to
5g fiber has some significant advantages
one is that it's future proof
the fiber that is a light conduit and it
sends a light signal down that conduit
it does not leak out of the conduit so
it's not you can't intercept it you
won't get any radiation from it and so
forth if we ever want to upgrade that uh
fiber in the future what you do is you
change out the equipment in the
so-called closet that's attached to the
fiber and and you get your new features
that way so the fiber network doesn't
need to be replaced okay
all of the wireless technologies as
you've noticed over the years become
you know supplanted by something else
that's more powerful and so forth what
we must not do is we must not build a
small
cell
antenna array because the next iteration
of of wireless is going to be even
higher power
so what we should do is we should look
at systems that are safe like fiber and
bring those into our homes and into our
schools into our workplaces and and use
that technology because
we
we know that light doesn't have the same
types of of biological and health
effects that
that
follow up
thank you mr chairman
but part of my question was speed
is there
is there an advantage over this 5d
compared to comparison no because the
frequency of light is even higher than
than 5g and and as you know there isn't
anything faster than the speed of light
so fiber is is the is the best that we
okay additional questions representative
oxenam did you have one my question was
answered
okay thank you any further questions
from the committee
seeing none i thank you mr wells for
your testimony thank you and i will now
courtney
gillardy
please remember you have three minutes
thank you
i will try and be brief
i have comments
but i know you asked for science instead
of just personal stories
i am here on behalf of the 17 people in
my neighborhood who was harmed
after a cell tower became active
your hands are not tied
there is no preemption when it comes to
health and human safety
you are required by law and the
constitution to do something about this
issue
the only thing that is unlawful and a
violation
is our government's officials failure to
act
yes we all want reliable high-speed
internet and how you heard this can be
accomplished is through fiber
there are no
safety standards for radio frequency
radiation
not from one tower
and no established safe levels of
wireless radiation
from the cumulative exposure of all the
sources of wireless radiation we are
exposed to today
our tower was tested at 1.66
of the fcc standards
so verizon came to our neighborhood and
told us it was safe
we are not
these are thermal standards
not biological cellular damage standards
these standards that the fcc have from
are invalid and not protective of our
health
of our children of our elderly of those
with pre-existing health conditions or
for any single one of us
these standards were based on a 220
pound dummy exposed to a cell phone for
six minutes
they do not affect for the fact that we
live next to these towers 24 7.
industry will tell you
that these towers
these macro towers are on the sides of
highways i will tell you that i have a
115 foot macro cell tower that is
capable of holding 48 cellular antennas
in my front yard
i have 17 neighbors experiencing
sickness and we have been called
collateral damage and the cost of doing
business
our doctors will tell you that we are
human subject experiments
this is illegal this is
not lawful and this is wrong
30 seconds plenty of science
we need to listen to the national
institute of toxicology the realm zeni
report and the world health organization
when it tells you this is a class ii
carcinogen
we need to listen to the fda who sends
letters to the fcc telling them that
they need to look at the biological harm
we need to look at our pediatricians who
are not surprised by the injuries
because the american academy of
pediatrics has a position statement from
10 years ago citing this harm and asking
for protections
because there is no risk management no
insurance policy and no help from local
or state health departments when it
comes to monitoring managing or
mitigating wireless emissions
something must be done thank you very
much did you submit written testimony
it is right here oh great it's right
here thank you so much and i know
amelia gillardy sitting next to you has
to go back to school soon so i'd like to
call on amelia right now and ask you
amelia if you could speak for three
minutes
esteemed legislators thank you for
allowing me to speak today in support of
hb 1644.
dr martin luther king jr said that our
lives begin to end the day we become
silent about the things that matter
i am here today because cell tower
setbacks matter
protecting people's health matters
the voice of my little sister and the 17
others harmed in my neighborhood after a
cell tower started transmitting matter
i have a dream that one day this nation
will rise up and look at the people who
are being injured by wireless radiation
and who have a medical diagnosis of harm
by their doctors and that instead of
treating them with shame and stigma our
legislators will deliver us the promise
of health safety and equitable
protections for all
i have a dream that one day be it in
sacramento california or shacktown
massachusetts
all people protected under the american
with disabilities act will actually be
protected because new hampshire was a
leader and passed setbacks here today
i have a dream that no one will have to
bear the high cost of legal
medical or relocation fees because you
have taken responsibility
in preventing toxic infrastructure from
being built in their neighborhood
here in new hampshire because of the
work you have done
i have this dream today
i dream of a world where everyone is
safe
where no one has to vomit in their own
bed or be forced to leave their house
and lose their home because of being
assaulted by an environmental toxin they
are exposed to without their consent 24
hours a day
seven days a
non-stop each of you here today have the
power to make protections from wireless
harm
more than just a dream
as someone disabled by wireless
radiation we need more than your prayers
we need policy change and protections
i am imploring you to protect your
residents by implementing cell tower
setbacks
the time is always right to do what is
right and that time is now
thank you
thank you two minutes and 20 seconds
very well done
and i know you have to get back to
school so we're going to forego any
questions of amelia and i have i thank
you both
representative thomas is recognized yes
uh to amelia it is extremely rare that
we have
minors testify in front of this
committee and is very much appreciated
and well done congratulations thank you
for coming
okay thank you i would point out that as
of this moment we have 24 minutes left
in this public hearing and i have 10
pink cards
left of people who want to speak
that likely means we will not get to
everyone so we will be
likely be recessing this public hearing
and resuming it at a later date
right now
i would like to call on
jennifer
friedman
remember miss friedman you have three
minutes
chairman votes uh
oxenom would it be possible for us to go
into the uh lunch period so that the
people who have actually come today
repeat the question please could could
we extend our public hearing into the
lunch period so that people who have
made the effort to be here today could
i don't think that's possible
i don't think it's
fair to ask members to
forego
an essential part of life
for example i intermittent fast
every day and i haven't not eaten yet
today so to forego my lunch would
require me to fast until dinner
and i really don't want to do that
before go lunch sir
only to cut down the time period
available
yeah i understand the question but we're
not going to do that thank you
thank you okay the floor uh
ms friedman is yours for three minutes
hello and thank you for hearing our
testimony today
my name is jennifer friedman i'm here
with my husband paul friedman
i'm a librarian paul is a small business
owner and we
live in keene
we'd always planned on moving to new
hampshire for retirement and our
retirement like many people got pushed
up a little
during the
pandemic
we found a beautiful house a home in
keene
a mile and a quarter from the downtown a
quarter mile from the bike path and
conservation trails
right across the street from the
dartmouth hitchcock-affiliated hospital
and
with enough bedrooms for our three
daughters um our three grown daughters
to come home
with
hopefully potential spouses and children
we
really believed that it was the perfect
early retirement home
we moved in september of 2020 about 16
months ago and settled in
uh everything was great until a week
before thanksgiving when we received a
letter from the city of keene director
of public works the letter read
dear property owner the city of keene
has received a small wireless facility
application from tilson tech for the
installation of a small wireless
facility to be located in the public
right-of-way in the area of three allen
court which is next door to us
tilson tech is proposing to construct a
swf consisting of a structure
approximately 40 feet tall
uh the letter went on to advise us that
the application and associated materials
were available for our review at the
public works department
um i then turned the letter over and saw
the pictures
of the 40-foot giant tower
superimposed on my neighbor's lawn
and the pictures were taken in such a
way that you could not see any houses
around it
it was taken from the point of view of
the house looking out onto the street
with the hospital in the parking lot in
the background
my neighbor's house is 50 feet
from this proposed tower my house is 92
feet
from that proposed tower this picture
showed a street
and a parking lot behind the street it
was completely
false
we went to review the file and we spoke
with public works director
it was then that we learned that tilson
tech had actually requested five permits
for five separate towers throughout the
city three of which were in residential
areas 30 seconds please um we spoke with
them
and uh the you know about our concerns
about the unknown health risks about the
decrease in our property value of a home
that we just purchased and he basically
told us his hands were tied there was
absolutely nothing that they can do and
my final paragraph
just to jump to it is that we fully
understand the importance of good
cellular service a high quality cellular
network will undoubtedly benefit the
entire community but right now the way
things are
private
for profit companies can come into a
city
and decide who bears the cost of that
public benefit
they decide
where these towers go and the state
doesn't get to say anything about it and
the city doesn't get to say anything
about it and they put it where it's the
easiest and most convenient for them
they don't look at whether it's in the
middle of a neighborhood they don't
think about any of them thank you very
much for your testimony we really
appreciate you coming down today
and
are there any questions
seeing none
i'll call on our next speaker
and because i know he has other things
to do i'd like to call on griffin
robarge of the state department of
welcome mr robarge
thank you mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is griffin roberge from the new
hampshire department of energy
here to testify in house bill 1644. um
i'll make it brief um the department is
only mentioned on page three
line 30
where it requires the department of
health and human services in
consultation with the department of
energy to establish fees to ensure the
cost of establishing maintaining and
advertising the online registry
established in this bill
per the fiscal note
the department of energy indicates i
have to adopt or modify rules governing
attachments made to public utility-owned
polls and structures
i think i'd have to agree with the
testimony from the department of health
and human services in that the bill does
not explicitly
um make any requirement for the
departments to undertake any rule making
but if we did
the cost would largely be negligible
um
just going a little further the
department of energy doesn't have any
expertise regarding the development or
cost or of implementing an online
registry
i know most of the responsibility
appears to fall to the department of
health and human services but
if the department of health and human
services were to consult with us again
we just don't have that adequate
experience to offer
additionally if this bill were to go
forward the department doesn't have any
funding to hire any expertise if needed
if we put together this registry or
helping to put together this registry
those are at least just some
technical concerns that the department
wanted to raise
at the public hearing today i'm
certainly willing to take any questions
the committee might have
thank you mr roberge let this be my
standing apology for mispronouncing your
name probably we'll do it again it's i
do not care
thank you very much
uh thank you for taking the question
and
i can only remember it
i'm sorry i'm going to have to pass
okay
any other questions for mr roberge
seeing none i'll thank you mr roberge
for your testimony thank you members of
the community and i'll call on the next
person
who is
stephanie
graham from
durham new hampshire
and miss graham y'all you'll have three
minutes but i'll remind you
that we're looking for scientific
data
and information
that relates to the substance of this
bill
and hearing a story about
your personal
property valued
thank you issues is not appropriate so
please thank you good morning and thank
you for allowing me to speak
um i actually wanted to talk about how
5g is a quantum leap compared to the
other generations of radio frequency
5g involves the entire microwave
spectrum that is 3 000 frequencies
not the 5 to 10 frequencies from
previous generations
if one does the math 5g should be called
297g
5g is designed to saturate
our homes schools and workplaces with
microwave frequencies of every kind
with no respite and with weapons grade
capabilities
we've heard from testimony from the
cellular telecommunications internet
association
everything wireless speaking about how
fcc supersedes other authorities
there is no amount of excuses for any
laws federal state or local that trump
the constitutional and natural laws that
state all men and women are free to make
decisions on how they should live in the
privacy of their homes
this is not only about accommodating
people who already are aware that these
frequencies are making them sick
it's about the fact
that these frequencies
have a negative impact on all living
things
your inaction on this bill would make
you complicit in placing men women and
children in direct harm
we do not need to provide proof of harm
although that does exist it is your
responsibility to prove to us
that this technology is safe
to date to date that is not possible
this technology is not safe and it's not
safe at levels well below what the fcc
claims is safe
virtually all non-thermal levels of
radiation even the extremely low ones
solicit damage to all living things
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony appreciate
you being here apparently she does not
want to accept any questions so we will
move on
and i will
ask
the next person
to come to the table that would be lisa
misdean i'll remind you you have three
minutes
and if you have written testimony which
i suspect you do please do not read it
we can read it later just summarize your
i'm actually going to read this
testimony for deb hobson who's not able
to join us today
my name is deb hopson and i have lived
in stratham for over 35 years as someone
whose health is seriously affected by
wireless i am acutely aware of the
potential cost of technology
thankfully i become knowledgeable enough
to successfully make choices to provide
a safe place in my home
and on my property while still having
the technology we all use daily
however the vast majority of the public
remains unaware you cannot make choices
for how to minimize risk without
knowledge especially if you do not
realize that a risk may even exist
it is clear that most think if there was
risk then they would not allow it
however there is no protecting health
and the environment in this industry
despite the assurances that there are
that is clear
some of the many effects of wireless
technology are insomnia headaches foggy
head or inability to think or focus
dizziness nausea skin issues severe dry
eyes and other pro eye problems
tinnitus heart arrhythmias difficulty
breathing which to some can be mistaken
for panic attack blood clotting issues
etc i had all of them i am sure many of
you know those who suffer with these
symptoms and some may be told they have
anxiety which may or may not actually be
what is happening there may be more to
the issue with regard to the potential
effects of wireless as in the case for
me
at one point i was very concerned that i
had some early onset dementia as i was
finding myself lost while driving in my
own hometown that was very frightening
thankfully i discovered what a major
factor in all of my issues rf radiation
which some refer to those of me like
electro hypersensitives or ehs
we learned
all we could with my health dramatically
improved when we hardwired our home
we ensured all wireless was off by
measuring with a meter and the plant in
our kitchen grew at least 15 inches in
two months
if a plant's growth can be that
dramatically affected imagine what is
happening to children
and those most vulnerable
my health issues resolved as long as i
avoid all wireless in today's world that
can be very difficult and very isolating
i could no longer use any public
transportation and travel i have great
difficulty entering public buildings
hospitals medical offices schools
churches restaurants and other people's
homes however i can control the
environment in my home and yard where i
spend most of my time as long as no
antenna or tower is built nearby
radiating into my property and
eliminating any choice or control in my
home environment
the ability to do that is critical
new hampshire was the first in the
nation to do its own independent
investigation on the health
environmental impacts of today's
wireless radiation i am thankful that
our republican state rep engineering and
our democratic state senator medical
doctor joined forces to sponsor that
bill this is not a partisan issue nor
should it be they listened
all right
clearly this will be one of the most
important issues of our time yet many
are completely unaware it even exists
except for the occasional news stories
on microwave attacks on u.s government
personnel the physical result is the
same for the rest of us even if it's
unintentional parents should not have to
face the anguish they inevitably
may feel years down the road when they
realize the harm they inadvertently put
their children in while thinking they
were keeping them safe because they did
not know
you have the opportunity to pass this
bill and support new hampshire
commission's findings as it begins to
take its first steps in implementing the
recommendations for new hampshire
citizens
thank you very much any questions for
since this was a
previously written testimony by someone
else i'll assume there'll be no
questions so thank you very much we
appreciate you being here to read that
thank you
okay so next up
and this very likely will be our last
testifier today
will be rick fabrizio
representing the business and industry
association
and uh remember we have a limit of three
minutes thank you very much thank you
out of respect for your time in the fact
that many of our points have been made
today we'll respectfully submit our
written testimony in place of speaking
we are here
as the
new hampshire statewide chamber of
commerce and leading business advocate
in respectful opposition to hp 1644.
thank you
thank you i have a question for you
in a town such as the one i live in
if this
1640 foot or 500 meter tower limit went
into effect
we wouldn't be able to install any
towers
in our town that
wouldn't impose on
one of those residential districts
the general public would accept
the fact
that
no 5g could come to my town because of
these red kind of restrictions
i know that beth cooley addressed that
point with the ctia about new hampshire
new hampshire residents speaking in
favor of the need for expanded broadband
including 5g
i wouldn't be able to speak to the
general feeling of the public however um
i think that most information points to
the need for expanded
online access to meet the ever-growing
increase in data transfer via online
okay thank you thank you representative
callie pitts has a question
well
thank you
the that expanded uh access because
we're all doing everything online now
except the legislature
could that be achieved with what we have
now
i'm not a subject matter on that but
if you look at the rate of growth of
data online um
what it's gone through the last 10 years
what it's projected to do over the next
five years
i think the case has to be made for
expanded
broadband i know that the state has been
working diligently to expand broadband
and 5g is part of that broadband network
may i follow
follow up
and i think we heard testimony that
and i i want to clarify that that fiber
could accomplish the same thing
that is the point that someone
previously made yes
representative oxenam is recognized for
okay thank you thank you any additional
seeing none i think we have reached the
end of our public hearing for today so
i'm going to officially recess
this committee
this public hearing rather
we still have four people who want to
speak and those four people will be
allowed to speak when we resume
the committee session at a date to be
determined later it will be published in
the house calendar so keep your eye on
the calendar to
discover
the date and the time of the resumption
of this public hearing mr clerk
be sure to note
in your notes that this hearing has been
recessed
and do do so in a manner that's clear
to the
administrators so that they don't
accidentally think that we completed the
public hearing here
okay
uh representative um you had a question
yes i do
so if others show up in this extended
hearing will you allow that testimony as
well or just before
we will allow
uh testimony for the length of that
resumed public hearing so i'm going to
schedule it for an hour
and we will allow testimony until we run
all right so we're going to take a lunch
break now from 11 30 to 12 30. we will
resume at 12 30 with our next bill which
is house bill 10
12.
before the committee meteor
members leave the building or leave the
room i need to inform everyone
that there has been a change
previously the
date for early bills was scheduled at
february 17th
that has been changed to february 10th
so
we will be exacting
[Music]
having executive sessions on our five
early bills of which this one is one
uh probably on
february 8th
because we only have this room on
mondays and tuesdays
we could possibly get the room on a on
the 9th or the 10th
the 10th at noon time would be the
the cut off
so
i'd be reluctant to to schedule an exec
session on the 10th
even if it was in the morning because it
would bump up against that deadline
to
there wouldn't be enough wiggle room
there to allow us to get our business
done so it's very likely going to be
exec session for the five early bills
maybe at three o'clock on february 8th
so
put that in your calendar and make sure
that you understand
that this is going to happen so that
everybody can make arrangements to be
here to vote on these five early bills
so with that no it's not next monday
february 8th
but
that's the next meeting
no february 8th is three weeks from now
we do have a meeting that day but monday
don't we have a another holiday coming
up on a monday so we're going to be
really behind the eight ball a little
bit
the next holiday is after february 8th
so
we have to get this done before that
yeah
my point is we can't meet two days
if we only have the room on mondays or
tuesdays we had a holiday this monday
we could meet on february 7th yeah
we could meet on january 31st
but uh i don't have any plans to do that
right now i'm going to try to get all
okay
thank you we'll see you at 12 30. no sub
committee
oh
yeah
everybody's going to agree on it so
hopefully get it across the line exactly
i wanted to grab i wanted to let you
know
um
okay welcome back everyone to the
afternoon session of the science
technology and energy committee for
january 18th
of 2022
we'll be hearing four bills this
afternoon
before i
go to the first bill i have a couple of
uh short announcements to make one is
that uh representative berezni is
celebrating her birthday today so be
sure to uh
we appreciate that promise
because some of us would really mess
another announcement i'd like to make is
that uh this morning
the senate energy and natural resources
committee
passed uh house bill 549
with an amendment ought to pass five to
nothing
and is sending it to the full senate and
recommending that it go on the consent
calendar
the amendment
essentially restored the energy
efficiency programs that were in place
before the recent triennium energy plan
was
uh rejected by the puc
but it restores them at the 2020 funding
levels and with the guard rails that
that hb 549 put in place for future
future years
so
when that bill comes back to the house i
will recommend that this committee in
the full house concur
with that bill with the senate amendment
so with those announcements we can now
turn to the
excuse me uh representative thomas
yes thank you mr uh
we're going to be passing around the uh
one of the previous presenters of the
last bill left behind some cds
um involving her subject and we're
passing them around here
for members and we have enough for every
member who even who isn't here and so if
you have someone you know isn't here and
okay so now let's move on to the
business of the afternoon and i would
like to
open the public hearing on house bill
relative to notice for the cutting of
trees
by utilities and i would first like to
recognize
one of the bill's sponsors the prime
sponsor representative william marsh
he is going to be testifying in
i hope i pronounced that correctly
wickesser of moultonborough so
representative marsh take it away thank
you mr chairman
good mor good afternoon and welcome to
members of the science technology and
energy committee it's good to join you
here today for the record i'm
representative william marsh carroll
county eight representing seven towns in
southern carroll county
and i'm here today to introduce house
bill 1012
relative to notice for the cutting of
trees by utilities i filed this bill as
a constituent request
and i forwarded my constituent paul
eckasser's written testimony to the
committee last week mr wekasaur is here
beside me and i'm hoping he'll be able
to testify after me i have one hard copy
for the clerk
briefly approximately thirty thousand
dollars in property damage occurred on
my constituent's property on
moultonborough neck on april 5th 2021
when a subcontractor of the new
hampshire electrical co-op removed trees
from this property without providing
appropriate notice
municipalities are required to provide
notice by registered mail under rsa
231-145
prior to non-emergent tree removal
utilities are not required to provide
the same notice and the intent of the
spill is to require that utilities
provide the same notice as towns
in the event the utility claims they
provided notice in my constituents
december 2020 utility bill which does
violate existing language
and rsa 231-172
i believe both consumers and utilities
are better off if notice is provided and
issues are resolved before trees are cut
down so i ask that you recommend this
bill ought to pass
other representatives have informed me
of similar occurrences elsewhere in the
state and i hope some of them will come
before you to testify today
i thank you i'll be glad to take
questions and with that i'm going to
hand the microphone to mr ruxin
thank you
mr weka sir hello thank you ladies and
jennifer let me talk before you today
right
sorry i'm new to this uh thank you for
letting me come before you today and uh
as rip marsh said i'm here because uh my
trees and all my neighbors trees and
everything the utility companies came in
they cut them all down
these weren't even trees that were above
the power line they were all small
ornamental bushes and like christmas
trees in the front yard of our homes and
they just came in and clear-cut
everything down they said to maintain
the lines the funny part is they didn't
cut down anything that would fall on the
trees and i would ask that you would
pass this legislation so that it would
be consistent with what everybody else
has to do as far as cutting the trees
you know the the towns and everything
have to give notice and
you know
just
there was a lot of property damage to
everybody in my neighborhood and you
know we were all kind of upset and
we all maintain our houses to impeccable
you know thing and
i guess
i guess that's thank you mr weka sir
i have a quick question for you did uh
the utility notify you by mail
ordinary mail in advance of this tree
cutting tree cutting operation
what they said is when i when i
approached them when they were out front
cutting down the trees is they said you
were notified by mail so i said i was
never notified by mail so i i went in
and i got my utility bill and what they
did is
behind the utility bill was like almost
like a pamphlet like sometimes you see
the pamphlets on how to save energy or
something or this there's a little
pamphlet on the back of one sheet page
like this and it just said uh
trees trees shouldn't be uh planted
underneath utility lines and then it
gave a list of uh trees and shrubs that
were approved to be planted within 11
feet of utility lines but it didn't say
anything about them cutting anything
down
it just said approved trees for under
power lines and stuff like that
like i said all of our trees on our
street were all
uh very well maintained and most of them
were just like have pictures here just
they were just small ornamental trees
that were
no way were endangering the power lines
uh well thank you for that answer as a
follow-up i would ask did anybody notify
you in person that this was going to
happen
no sir nobody notified i didn't know i
came out uh out of my house and there
was a subcontractor i think name was
asphalt or something
and they were there and there was an
arborist from uh the new hampshire
electric co-op and they were cut and i
asked them what they were doing and they
said we're clearing the lines and i
asked them i said what do you mean
clearing the lines i said my trees my
tallest tree is eight foot tall
they're little things they cut all the
shrubs everything even flowers
clear-cut
i mean clear-cut everything
like i said it was it was all over
thirty thousand dollars worth of damage
by the time they were done
did you ask the arborist to cease and
desist
i not only asked him to cease and desist
i called the police department the
mountainboro police department came down
and they refused to do anything they
okay
are there any additional questions
representative nodder
thank you i have two questions the first
one is these are trees and shrubs and
plants that you you personally planted
not
yes
my home is located on lake winnipesaukee
uh and uh there there are a lot of
high-end homes around me and all of
everybody it was all maintained by
stephen's uh landscape and most
everybody my street hasn't maintained
and i have some pictures here that uh
the before and after of it so they yeah
they were all ornamental trees basically
is what i would call them
follow up
follow up thank you mr um chair
um
i had to intercede for one of my
constituents over a tree
and we had success by contacting the
department um
i guess it was not unitil eversource
did do you um contact
the co-op i contacted the co-op i had uh
several uh
correspondence back and forth with uh
many of the people on the board
um also
uh
don't quote me on this it was a chairman
or a executive chairman or something
like that
um
and they basically just all told me we
got the right to cut down anything 11
feet on either side of the thing unless
it's an approved tree i
i really got nowhere with them uh they
their attitude just was and the
gentleman that was the arborist that was
actually on side of the thing
i don't like to use these words but he
was probably one of the most arrogant
uh
representative thomas is recognized for
a question thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question just for
clarification uh you may have said this
but i may have not heard
the
trees and shrubs that were cut down were
they within the utilities right of way
uh in actuality where the pole is on my
property in 2015
uh if you remember the big ice storm
that we had up here
uh the couple of trees the pole used to
be across the street
and trees fell during that ice storm and
they fell
over the thing and when they moved the
pole they moved it to the other side of
the street where my house is
and from for
since 2015 they kept sending me a thing
every year asking me to give them an
easement on my property because they
didn't even have an easement where the
pole was and i refused to give them the
easement for the thing
and i didn't tell them to take it down
either you know but uh
their their basic thing was
we have a right to cut 11 feet
where the power lines are over overhead
11 feet either side of them unless
anything unless it's an approved
planting that's on our list which
consisted about three or four plants but
as you can see from these photos
everything from the flowers and
everything
got clear-cut
follow up
follow-up
uh thank you mr chair thanks for the
follow-up um
and to the best of your knowledge
did the co-op
give you any avenue for appeal prior you
know prior to the work
no what i what i ended up doing was
i spent over two hundred thousand
dollars of my own money
and i buried all of the utilities
underground
and they said they would work with me on
that as far as
the permitting and stuff like that which
they did but it was all at my cost
okay representative harrington is
recognized for a question
yes this would go to the sponsor of the
bill um
looking at the bill it there's a couple
of things on here that i'm just it
doesn't seem to be too clear certainly
not not much guidance
the owner refuses to consent the
selectmen of that town
will then determine if it's necessary to
remove the uh
the cutting or retreat
and also determine what the damage was
to the owner and then they can award
them
well let me just start with that
question how do they do how are they
going to determine if the tree is
necessary to be brought down and
determine how much the damage was done
to the owner
can you give me the line place that
you're looking at sure i saw 17 and 18.
okay that that's existing language in
so that's always been that way right the
the changes that this bill would make
are in bold italic which is the usual
custom that we do when we draft bills
okay follow-up mr chairman may i have a
copy of whoever people are looking at
back there on the table
uh follow-up representative harrington
yeah in the next paragraph down d on
line 19 this is involved it says a
licensee who fails to abide by this
paragraph she'll be liable for no less
than two times the damage is incurred
and no more than 10 times the damage is
incurred so just assuming that somehow
the selectmen are able to determine the
damage
what guidance do they have as to whether
they should be assessing 10 times the
damage or two times the damage because
i think that's a valid comment um
the point of the
paragraph d is that a law without teeth
tends to get ignored as existing law
that required notice to my constituent
was ignored so if we have no penalty in
the law then there's no reason to expect
thank you representative callie pitts is
recognized
i seem to remember
that we have had this discussion before
about cutting trees on private property
and that
we had a group meeting and it was
agreed between the stakeholders the
utilities that they would notify people
that the trees were to be cut
or
were pending to be cut and that would be
a very clear notification that they were
going to do that
and in my town they have to post the
trees that they're going to cut
they have to actually put a paper on the
tree saying it's slated to be cut
i don't know about wolfeboro but
enforcement they do
if you had discussed
with
the
utility
that there has been an agreement
and we expect the utilities to stand by
the agreement to
discuss with people
that
tree said to be cut on private property
that they have to be and that if
a mistake is made or somebody does
something without knowledge that there
would be recompense
and did you go to an arbitration um
what i what i tried to do was i i
as i said i had several phone calls with
the co-op board members and
everybody involved there then i went to
the public utilities commission
and i spoke and then forgive me but i
don't remember her name i went up and i
saw later it's public utilities and she
said that utilities like eversource and
stuff like that they do have an
agreement to mock and probably notice
she said the co-op the new hampshire
electric co-op does not fall under any
and that and she said so they don't have
to
do that
follow up so should i yes my follow-up
would be then should this bill be
that i guess would be a question for you
guys good sponsor
that would be acceptable to me
representative thank you
thank you
okay thank you representative mick
williams is recognized for a question
thank you chair bose
so just to follow up on this discussion
we're having about
penalties and also making sure that this
actually applies to the new hampshire
electric co-op
i'm looking at the existing language
here on line two roman numeral two a
licensee shall provide notice
so i i apologize that i haven't had an
opportunity to look at the full rsa
but for rsa 231 172 when we're talking
about a licensee are we just talking
about these recognized large utilities
or does the new hampshire electric co-op
actually fall under the definition of
licensee
uh i'm sorry i don't know the answer to
your question okay can i ask a follow-up
follow up okay
um so i think in order for us to
actually make sure that this works to do
what you intend i think we need to
understand who a licensee is or tweak
this to actually achieve your goal
but i also want to just point out that
lines 19 through 21 where you're talking
about two times damages incurred and no
more than 10 times damage is incurred
that's a pretty broad range if we're
talking about 30 000 worth of damage
right two times is sixty thousand but
ten times is three hundred thousand so
you know that that window just seems
extreme and we are not a court of law
we're the legislature so who's applying
the two to ten times who decides that
two to ten times is there some kind of
an adjudication adjudication process to
determine where you fall in the spectrum
in terms of damages i'm not seeing that
from the language in the bill so i want
to know how that would work if we were
to use the exact language in the bill or
if it needs an amendment when you when
you look at when you are
sorry when you look at the law regarding
tree cut in the state of new hampshire
there is laws on the books now and there
are cases i can't cite them off the top
of my head i'm not a lawyer where when
trees were cut on private property it
has been brought before the courts and
the court determined that depending on
damages and put that but there is
case law numerous case law in the state
regarding that
two times to ten times law and that's
assessed by the court as as the court
sees fit
so it requires a lawsuit to get your two
to ten hundred it does require it does
require the lawsuit to get to get to
that yes
thank you uh representative mcwilliams
i'm looking at
section 231
of
191 sub chapters subsections
and it would take us a while to figure
out what licensee means but i i
i take your point i think it's a good
one we need to find that out before we
can
decide what uh how to proceed
okay uh representative bernardi is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
and
so
as i understand your bill
you're predominantly in addition to this
this issue of
penalties you're looking for a better
defined notice
but what i heard you talk about was
damages to
small ornamental trees uh and and
flowers and and whatnot um
which reasonably shouldn't have been cut
because they're not on the no cut list
so i'm wondering if if you can comment
on whether or not
that no cut list should be amended
to reflect that kind of vegetation
and the reason i ask that is because
the
utilities have gone through my town
recently and
under all the major
power lines they're going in and they're
just cutting everything down but if it's
uh
and they have big right-of-ways under
these big power lines but uh
under
local you know polls
that go through people's yards along the
roadside they're just trimming
the tall trees that might fall in
they're not cutting
any of the vegetation on the ground this
seems very strange that it happened
there and maybe that needs to be
addressed as
they well that was the funniest part
about it they didn't cut anything that
was all higher than the than that than
the uh
than the uh
the power lines everything they cut on
the whole road
follow-up
follow-up and if it had the opportunity
to grow up and entangle in the power
lines that would make sense if they were
going to do it every five years and say
okay you know five years from now this
thing's going to be in the power lines
let's get it now but if it's an
ornamental tree
that's only going to grow eight feet
those things should be exempt so i'm
wondering if you maybe want to amend
this or address this to focus in on
utilities not taking down that kind of
vegetation
well all all of my trees could have i
guess not all of them but a lot of them
could have a lot of more spruce trees
could have grown up that high
if they were not maintained
and i can even understand the utility
companies coming in and cutting down
trees if they're not maintained but if
somebody's maintaining their property
and if you look at 231 you read on to it
a neighbor has a right to cut your
branches if they're hanging over your
house and doing damage to your house
which is understandable you know and the
utility companies should have to use the
same type of discretion if it's at the
point where it's going to damage their
lines
understandable but if i'm maintaining my
tree whether it's hanging over your roof
and i'm cutting it back so it doesn't
damage your property or i'm keeping it
below the power lines you know there
there needs to be a little bit of common
thank you
thank you uh representative cambrils is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman just for clarification uh the
power lines in this particular case were
they
distribution lines or were they the
bigger transmission lines uh they're
just regular uh
regular i guess you call transmission
lights it's a small uh lake front road
it's a dirt road
distribution coming to a local residency
okay
the representative partial is recognized
that's following up on thank you chair
following up on the question by
uh by somebody else
uh do i understand correctly that they
did not have an easement for the
placement of the poll they put there in
correct and did you pursue any kind of
trespass suit against ibm's second
um did you pursue a trespass
suit against them no that's actually
when i called the police i told him that
there was they had didn't even have a
right for the poll to be there and i
asked him to stop them from cutting and
he said he said i'm not going to get
involved in that he says take that up
with the courts and to be honest with
you i'm not the type of person that
wants to spend my time in a courthouse i
would rather page to fix it uh and like
i said this this is more just
that i think the co-op should have to
follow the same consistent rules that
the towns and municipalities the bigger
utility companies they should have to
follow the same rules i mean we should
all follow the same rules
thank you so i
uh one quick question before i recognize
representative callie pitts
i assume you are a member of the co-op
ah yes i guess so so you actually are
part owner of the of the co-op
that's the way it works right i i guess
i don't know i get a bill in the mail
and i pay it i don't know if that makes
any difference to how they treat
uh
their members but um the trees and so on
and so forth but it's
it's worth having on record
i turned it off i'd like to clarify with
the sponsor and with you sir
would you be amenable to amending this
to make it
conform
with making the co-op conform to what
the other utilities do which is they
have to notify and they have to post and
they have to make sure you are notified
in a clear
in a clear manner
i was going to say you guys understand
the organization of utility companies a
whole lot better than i do all i know is
that i have an angry constituent who got
his trees cut down and he would like to
know this isn't going to happen again
right and and more than one actually i
talked to some of the neighbors we've
done we've we've had this discussion and
we had an agreement with the other
utilities so
we should bring this utility
either with legislation or whether you
in agreement in front of the puc
into conformance
but we can we can do it by legislation
thank you representative
any further questions for these two
gentlemen seeing none
i noticed that
ms gamache from eversource has signed up
to testify she may have some
information for us that will be
revealing but before we get to that
testimony i want to call
representative kat mcgee who is a
co-sponsor of this legislation to
testify
on its behalf
thank you chairman bose and esteemed
colleagues
i'll be quick
because i think most most of our points
have been covered
as the prime sponsor has made clear the
impetus for this bill comes from one
constituent mr weckesar right here
based on his financial
significant financial loss that he
contends was unnecessary for the removal
of 13 ornamental trees that he
maintained
regularly
and which he says were no
pose no threat to the utility lines
it comes down to a request for a more
clearly defined due process
as there is dispute both as to whether
the affected constituent was given
proper notice and also whether there was
any opportunity to respond or dispute
the decision to impose thirty thousand
dollars worth of damage on a private
land owner
um mr weckerser's letter contends he's
already doing more than the average
citizen to maintain both his own
property and state-owned property that
abuts his property
with consideration for safety and also
the health of the trees
so the bill asks for simple language
changes that clarify how the utilities
are to notify landowners who are
scheduled for tree removal and of course
we already discussed that it includes
penalties to try and give teeth to that
law
and i think that the
231 and it's 191 subsections to just
make sure that the electric co-op is
actually
uh covered as a licensee under the
language that is listed in this brief
bill
um makes sense and if that if it's not
appropriately covered that we come up
with an amendment to do that and i would
be happy to work on that and help make
that happen
um i was not aware that this kind of
clear-cutting uh that surprised mr
weckerser was even possible without
registered mail notification and that's
why i opted to sign on as a co-sponsor
on the bill
and now that it's been brought to our
attention i would ask my colleagues to
consider this a utilitarian fix to
statute that does not currently cover a
thank you representative mcgee any
questions for
representative mickey now seeing none
we'll um
thank you again representative and move
on to our next speaker unbeknownst to me
when i mention miss gamache a few
minutes ago
michael liccato who is a vice president
at new hampshire electric co-op happens
to be
in attendance and i'm sure he
will have much illuminating information
to provide
on this question so i'm going to call to
the stand now michael lacada of new
yeah mr uh wickester you might want to
thank you uh mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record michael
akata with new hampshire electric co-op
i apologize that was a minute or two
late so i couldn't hear the full extent
of the sponsor and the constituents
testimony
so i can't speak to this specific
constituent's
situation
but i can speak to new hampshire
electric co-ops practices and policies
and the statutes that we're required to
conform to
in terms of tree trimming and
notification to constituents so
to answer representative kelly pitts's
question
just right off the bat
this statute does apply to new hampshire
electric co-op we are a
regulated distribution utility in the
state of new hampshire
a little confusion sometimes for folks
we are not rate regulated uh because we
are a non-profit member owned
cooperative so
when we set our electric distribution
rates those do not have to be approved
by the public utilities commission
they're approved by our board of
directors
but we do have to comply with the
statutes and
of the state of new hampshire so
in terms of the requirement for a 45-day
notification
before vegetation management or tree
trimming that is something that we have
to do and that we do comply with
we send out
notices via mail to our members to their
the mailing address that we have on file
monthly utility bills
if we it is a non-member property owner
we utilize the municipal tax records for
the mailing address and that is where we
would send the notification i would note
that we have a large number of seasonal
members second homes
and so it is possible that uh
folks are either in between their two
locations and it is possible that they
do not get the the mail notification but
we we make every effort to send the
notification to their mailing address on
file we actually exceed uh the statutory
requirement
uh we send a
phone call two to three weeks before we
go on to
an area for trimming
to have further notification again this
is provided
via the phone number that we have as a
contact information for the member on
file
i would say again i can't speak for um
the gentleman's experience i would be
happy to talk to him afterwards it
sounds like he's made several inquiries
to the co-op on this
uh subject
but we do
quite frankly make every effort to work
with our members i think as all
utilities do with their customers and
property owners
to make sure they're informed on the
extent of the cutting to understand
why we're cutting and uh you know the
the
reasons for that and quite frankly
there are situations where if we
go outside the right-of-way if we cut a
tree that we're not supposed to we do
try to work with those individuals and
we do
try to repair property damage if it
occurs that could be
reseeding a lawn that could be planting
ornamental trees
and so i would be happy to
you know
learn more about what happened in this
particular situation and talk to the
folks back at the co-op so we are
concerned with the legislation as
drafted
we are compliant as i said we actually
go a bit above and beyond in terms of
our notifications uh then we're required
to
i would agree with uh or
we have a number of the same questions
that committee members raised on the
penalties that are
listed in the legislation uh who
determines the extent of the damage and
the cost associated uh is that the
utility is it the property owner is it a
third party is it a court is it a
selectmen
and then how those are applied
as well
it was noted uh the two to ten times
damage how was that determination made
again is that um
ultimately a legal decision and i would
just add uh at the end of the day as a
non-profit
member-owned utility
ultimately any additional costs that we
are
uh that we assume for certified mail for
uh you know sort of punitive damages
required ultimately is recovered by all
of our members through our rates we
don't have profits we don't have
shareholders uh really our our electric
members as
the chairman pointed out who are our
member owners um
are responsible for the cost so
i would be happy to answer any questions
that i
am able to
and
i will be providing written testimony uh
electronically
thank you mr lakota it's great to see
you again i have a couple of quick
questions for you by any chance you know
what the definition of licensee in
rsa231 colon 172 is
i i don't have it at the fingertips but
i would assume
it applies to the distribution utilities
who do the cutting
are responsible for the cutting
my second question is a little more
detailed i serve on the planning board
in my town of epping
and when
eversource or new hampshire electric
co-op both of whom serve my town
want to do tree cutting in our town they
hire subcontractors
and those subcontractors are required to
come before the planning board to tell
the planning board
where they're going to cut
what hours they're going to use for you
know to do their cutting
and who
a property owner could contact if they
had a question
about what the subcontractor was doing
so my question for you is
in the area where mr wickster lives do
you use subcontractors and are they
subject to the same kind of planning
board scrutiny that they are in my town
uh we do use subcontractors to do the
actual trimming um we have arborists uh
on staff who oversee the
that in terms of um
the municipality interaction um
i'll have to double check uh but
certainly we would essentially treat all
the municipalities the same and follow
the statutes so
uh i would like to say yes but i would
want to check with our team
okay thank you
representative plett is recognized for a
question thank you for taking my
question mr lecotte your representation
of what you do
appears to be different than the
testimony we heard from the
party who was affected so i it asks you
to go through your records
and check out what did happen
and meet with the landowner and see what
you can work out i'd be happy to thank
you
thank you mr thank you for taking my
question uh just for clarification i i
believe it's been at least established
by the cons by the previous speaker
that the poll in question was
not given a right of way and was i guess
still on his private property
do you happen to know because i don't
do you happen to know if any of the
statutes address
the cutting of trees
when
the
property in question has not been given
a right of way in its private property
do they have to get written permission
so to speak before they can go on there
and do any cutting yeah i i
i don't know the answer i would assume
that all of the applicable statutes uh
would be in effect uh again i i don't
know the specific circumstance in terms
of an easement or a lack of an easement
um and so
i'd be happy to
work with the gentleman and learn more
about the situation and see what
what happened
quick follow-up
thank you mr chair uh so
um yes please do because
it almost looks like we're looking like
at a situation here where if you have a
a piece of utility property that hasn't
been given appropriate right of way
might be in conflict perhaps for the
statute so it would be very good of you
to find that out please
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
the
the witness in this case said
the name of the contractor ashfonder i
think and that's the one everybody uses
i
now you got to turn it on
i wonder
if the notice that the was mentioned on
the back of the bill
that there was going to be tree cutting
in the area
was that the notice that was mailed or
is there an individual letter and if
there is
i would
assume
again you're doing assuming so i'm going
to assume that there is a copy of that
letter someplace
and i would like to know that before we
have to vote on a bill i think this can
be worked out amicably i don't know if
you do
but
i would like to know that all the things
that was supposed to happen or that you
say happened
happen
understood so to answer the first
question the requirement under statute
is we can't just put a notification on
the back of a bill it has to be an
individual letter that is mailed uh and
i will
get the gentleman's contact information
follow up my follow-up is that
when an owner
confronts
a worker and supposedly a representative
of the company who is the company
arborist
and says cease and desist
that
that particular person
or that particular company doesn't make
a phone call
or
that to me
is something that needs to be handled at
the company too it wasn't that this was
a remote thing it was a personal
cease and desist stop
and on his own property so i would like
also i would like you to investigate
i know they're hot people are hired to
do a job
however
they should have at least notified
somebody in authority above and beyond
the arborist and i would assume that
there are people in the company who
would act in that capacity so can you
see if there was any notification of
that incident prior
remember we're here to ask questions i
would like to know that okay yeah
as i said i i'm not familiar with the
situation uh with this individual
constituent
i'm happy to
have a conversation with him to learn
more and also have a conversation with
um
our team at nhc
okay representative jd bernardi is
recognized for a question
thank you chairman uh mr licotta
do you have a procedure once a
party has been notified that there will
be tree cutting trimming
in their area
for that
those individuals to to
have a discussion with
whoever is going to do the job not to
cut down ornamentals and flower beds and
other such
vegetation or do they just show up and
do it no yes we do um you know again i
can't speak to the situation um that
occurred
but
that is our goal is to have a
conversation we have had
instances where i have spoken to const
to members where our team has spoken to
members and they have marked certain
trees they've marked certain sensitive
areas that they don't want um
impacted so
that is our goal if
i don't know what happened in this
situation but that is is our goal and
what we strive to do
okay representative harrington is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question i just want to make this clear
because it seems to be this seems like a
new part we're kind of opening up and
whether we need more adjustments to the
law does your company have a policy that
addresses
i come out of my house you've sent
someone over to cut down trees and i say
get off my land
what is the what is your policy on how
i'm going to have to
circle back on that to give you an
accurate answer i don't want to tell you
the wrong thing
follow up
just want to say that that's that to me
is the heart of the issue right here
because if there's no policy and effect
at that i think we need to make an
amendment to this bill thank you
okay thank you
see no further questions for mr lakota
appreciate you being here today looks
like you've got some homework to do and
thank you i'm sure you'll get back to us
with with detailed answers
we have two more people who would like
to testify and i'd like to call on donna
gamache from eversource and then jason
stock of the timberland owners
association ms gamache the floor is
yours
good afternoon thank you very much for
the opportunity to testify i'm glad that
mike went before me
so i don't have to speak to some of the
things that he already spoke to
eversource is concerned about the bill
should it pass as is
we think that it will
be uh costly it'll slow down our tree
trimming process and there's a lot of
loose ends you you all heard it already
and you know mainly the big concern for
us also is you know who determines the
extent of the damage and then how do you
apply you know the penalty so that one
we had a big question about but i
thought what i would do
is just very quickly let you know why we
even have how these rules have evolved
over time
eversource before we were ever sourced
we were public service of new hampshire
and like in the late 80s early 90s we
were having some great financial
difficulty and in working with the
public utilities commission at the time
they were very intent on trying to not
escalate the costs our rates for
customers as quickly as they were they
were rapidly increasing so the puc
determined that we they would we would
slow down on our tree trimming programs
for quite a number of years it turned
out by doing that yes we did keep costs
down but our customers were severely
unhappy because we had outages we had
outages short term long term
and so they slowly determined that we
had to start spending money on dreaming
again to try to get this under control
as you can imagine for our customers
there's probably two things that matter
most to them how much they're paying on
their bill and do they have an outage in
how long do they have an outage
in fact the public utilities commission
they on a regular basis monitor
the duration of an outage the duration
between outages and how we do in in in
responding them to them and getting
everything restored where in fact uh
they they um i'm trying to think of the
word they um they grade us on that and
that impacts how we even our rate
recovery so they use they when we sit
down and ask for a you know a rate case
we go through all of that in fact after
every storm
we have to do a report and they
investigate how we did it and what
potentially could we have done
differently in advance of the storm to
make sure that that was less of an
outage so um many of you remember the
ice storm of 2008
that one was mainly it was obviously
caused by ice but mainly it was the ice
on the trees
and the trees took down so many lines
that it was it was unusual to have for
the most part for a 14 day outage
our customers and legislators were very
very unhappy at that time so
and this may be what you're talking
about um representative kelly pitts but
we may have done it more than once but
right after that ice storm a group of
legislators pulled all the utilities in
and said we have to find a balance how
is it that you're notifying your
customers about your tree trimming
what can we do to make it easier so at
the time
we had to get permission from our
customers to trim the trees and that
wasn't working because we couldn't term
a tree if we didn't get the permission
so the legislature determined at that
time that we would flip it
and so a law was passed that allowed us
to notify customers that we were going
to trim and give them 45 days to let us
know if they did not want us to trim and
then we would go out and talk to them
and figure out is there something we can
do how can we how can we trim the tree
and still make you happy and if we can't
we'll put it aside and deal with it
later so for eversource we have a little
over a half a million customers for us
to have to notify our customers by
registered mail would be
highly expensive not only that not on
tree trimming because we don't do it but
in other instances when we determine
that we have to reach out to a customer
by registered mail i'm not going to say
every customer does that but we have
customers who will not answer the door
and sign for that
so it that becomes a problem also so
what we will do in certain instances
where we know it's super sensitive we're
not hearing back we'll put door hangers
so that the customer will see the door
hanger and they and then they have the
information about who to contact and we
try to
resolve the situation there's always
going to be times when it didn't go well
accidents happen but i would say
generally speaking we've got a really
good process going and we'd like to be
able to keep the balance that we
currently have i do want to just mention
you probably know this many of you
probably already know this but there is
a difference in the way we trim
and what the requirements are for
distribution and transmission
after the blackout of 2003 which did not
affect new hampshire thank god we were
able to shut off the spigot and protect
ourselves but you know that it started
in ohio it went all across eastern
united states the federal government
determined the federal government
regulates transmission so the federal
government determined at that point
that it was a tree that started that
outage and so they were going to
institute completely new policies and
penalties associated with tree trimming
on um transmission lines i see it it's
happening in my town where i live now
i call it sad to say the scorched earth
policy that
nothing grows they come through and
nothing grows under those transmission
lines and that's a requirement of the
federal government and if utilities do
not comply
they get a million dollar i think it's a
day a million dollar a day fine
for not ensuring that that trimming is
done appropriately so in closing if you
do decide to move forward with a bill if
we could talk about finding a balance
that would be terrific thank you very
much
thank you
ms gamache for that testimony as an
aside
recall previous years in this committee
we always imposed fines for people who
forgot to turn off their cell phones
anyway
representative kreshan is recognized for
a question
thank you chair thanks for taking my
question um it's just in regard to the
the door hangers that you mentioned in
cases where it seems sort of sensitive
can you just tell me a little bit more
about how you make that determination of
when further outreach is required
i wish i could i'm very sorry i don't
know how we know
i can tell you that our crews we
obviously work with contractors we use
asplin sometimes we use brown as well
we regularly go through cycles
my understanding is they tend to know
but sometimes it's it we find out later
that it's sensitive i do want to just
state it may be helpful
i have been talking with the uh chairman
of the committee to bring in our
arborist uh we're expanding our arborist
team and
we're trying to come up with a day that
works for everybody that he might be
able to walk you through exactly how we
do what we do and answer your questions
i will say he's fascinating he's created
an arboretum
that
that what he's intending to do is
educate communities and then long-term
um individuals about the types of growth
that work with uh distribution and
transmission license representative came
in and visited our arboretum so uh
anyway for the f he might be able to
answer that question in the meantime if
you'd like i can get try to get an
answer for that thank you so much you're
welcome
okay thank you we uh need to move on
uh representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr thanks for taking my
question really quick
to the best of your knowledge on the
statutes
do they make a distinction whether or
not they apply to
your rights of ways or
um
i know that in terms of rights of ways
the different rights of ways there's
certain clearing levels that we're
supposed to meet there must be inter
like if you think about like the city of
manchester we have polls going down
streets there are trees they must have a
different set of requirements as well i
can't imagine that they that they would
apply the same because it's a different
type of trimming
okay thank you you're welcome
thank you ms gamache jason stock you
have
the grand total of six minutes
including questions
but i know you can handle it thank you
for the for the record i'm jason stock
i'm the executive director
excuse me new hampshire timberland
owners association and
i just wanted to share with you some
information about timber values and this
bill caught our attention because we
deal in the world of doomage that's the
term used to
value standing timber timber
and so we saw this bill
and one of our policy committee members
is a forester and also an arborist and
doomage three in this case two to ten
times
has been applied to ornamental trees um
on what's called a timber trespass so to
answer representative thomas's question
when you have a piece of land and it's
you own the land fee simple and someone
comes over and cuts your trees that's
considered a timber trespass
um and the law entitles you to dumage
which is ten to ten three in in terms of
the timber harvesting laws
three to ten times the value of that
stumpage and that's the
and those values are derived from the
department of revenue who calculates
stumpage which is then used to calculate
your timber tax
um we got involved in this issue a
number of years ago because what we were
seeing out there was
doomage being applied to ornamental
trees and this arborist mem committee
member of ours
was seen situations where someone cut a
tree say a maple tree about
eight to ten inches thick
and
they cut it
and then
damages are applied and what they did
was to calculate the damages the
attorney came in
went down to the nursery and found out
what the value of a maple sapling is
extrapolate extrapolated that out to the
value of an eight to ten inch tree and
then added ten times and in a couple
instances the value of a couple trees
was worth more than probably the entire
parcel
um so again we don't i just wanted to
kind of i wasn't really planning to
testify today but i heard a lot of
questions about timber values and how do
you how do you determine what is in this
case they're using a two to ten times
the value
you know that's usually part of a
negotiation between parties that are
trying to determine that are typically
negotiating a timber trespass
applying that to an ornamental tree is
is really inappropriate
to apply that
right now what typically happens is i
understand it from our my committee
member who gets involved in these
disputes is that
rsa
634 which is the criminal
criminal uh criminal mischief
destruction of property law that's what
really typically kicks in when you have
an ornamental tree or property damage
not the timber harvesting laws which
apply doomage
so again i i wanted to provide you some
information i'm feeling compelled to
check a box on the
on the on the card i did check that we
oppose the bill just for the mere fact
that we think we're not opposed yet
we're ambivalent on the
notice provision but we do think that
applying
a a doomage type factor to an ornamental
tree is is really not appropriate and
with that i'll conclude my testimony
fascinating uh stuff all over the world
whenever you testify i always learn
something new and
i'm glad to add timber trespass and
doomage to my
my knowledge bank thank you any
questions for mr stock
seeing none i would like to thank you mr
stock for testifying we'll see you
tomorrow morning i guess and
[Music]
tomorrow morning in r r and r
representative thomas will be
introducing a bill
to
create a study commission to
study uses of low-grade timber in the
state of new hampshire and i'm a
co-sponsor on that bill
and our rnr will hear that bill tomorrow
morning
but with that
testimony we'll close the public hearing
on house bill
and
we'll take a
two-minute break
so people can
have a bio break and then we'll start
okay i'd like to now open the public
hearing on house bill
1116 relative to renewable energy
customer generator accounts
and credits
and i would like to turn the floor over
to the bills bill's prime sponsor
representative rebecca mcwilliams
representative
thank you chairvoz and colleagues
members of the science technology and
energy committee for the record my name
is rebecca mcwilliams i represent the
west side of concord
i'm here today because i've
run across an issue that seems to be
an emerging concern
for small businesses and possibly large
businesses across the state of new
hampshire
so just a little bit of background as to
why this bill and why now um
as you may know
my family owns and runs a family farm
here in concord
and we recently had a ground mount solar
system installed
last summer
the system is hooked up to our farm's
barn meter
which is the electric meter for the farm
stand and the barn
we also have an electric meter that's
for the house which controls the well
pump that's usually our most expensive
electric thing is the well pump for the
fields
as well as obviously we have some
lighting that gets very expensive around
now january and february when we're
growing seedlings inside
so like
pretty much every single farm in new
hampshire we have more than one electric
meter
and so the reason that's important is
because when a farm does something like
installing solar panels
they have to decide which meter to
install the panels to connect to and in
our case we've been successful in
accumulating some credits spinning that
meter backwards
but there is another meter associated
with that business and so we would like
to be able to transfer that excess
credits for the solar panels to the barn
and farm stand
to the house
because that's where the well pump is
and so we knew going in that unitil
who is our utility will only allow us to
transfer credits once a year that's just
their policy
and it varies by um utility i know
eversource has a different policy than
unitil and i don't actually know what
the electric co-ops policy is but having
these different policies makes it
difficult for businesses across the
state to make decisions about how
they're going to handle their
electricity and if they become a
consumer generator what they're going to
do with those excess credits
so
think of this bill as somewhat of a
rough draft to begin the conversation
about how we can better address this
because i do think we have quite a few
businesses who would benefit when they
have multiple meters
having the ability to once a month make
the decision to apply that credit to a
different account that's associated with
their business
so it's really i'm just going to read it
because it is such a short bill
literally what we're doing is inserting
a new paragraph in the net energy
metering surplus credit
rsa 362 a9 we're adding a new paragraph
it says notwithstanding other provisions
of this section a customer generator
with more than one account
may elect monthly to have any surplus
associated with one account credited to
the consumer generator's other account
or accounts
so really we're talking about being able
to slide that money over to your other
account now there are a lot of things
that this does not say and i've received
quite a bit of feedback since i
submitted this to
ols a couple months ago
so there are some things to talk about
the first is i don't mention your
utility
i think it makes sense to amend this to
say something about it needs to be under
the same utility
so obviously if you have a farm that has
a property that is split down the middle
and half is eversource and half as
unitil you wouldn't be able to transfer
between the two utilities so i think
amending this to say it's under one
utility makes sense
another one is there's the potential for
a really large business and i'm not
going to call out any of their names but
there are some very large businesses who
are large landowners
who may be able to you know take huge
advantage of this and it may be unfair
for the utility or it may be unfair the
way that they're approaching this
so i think it is reasonable to discuss
potentially capping this at a dollar
value per year okay so in my situation
when we're talking about a family farm
and our electric bills
we are not spending more than ten
thousand dollars
and that's sort of you know
we're small but we're not spending more
than 10 grand on any of our electric
bills but we could get up there when
we're talking about you know
the commissioner of agriculture has a
family chicken farm and it has many
properties with many utility meters
commissioner jasper obviously i i know
he's neutral on this bill but i want to
just say that as an example of an ag
implication where there are many meters
and many properties it may make sense
that the cap be something that's still
reasonable but not obscene for you know
a monster business so so putting some
numbers out there and perhaps coming up
with something that's reasonable but not
unfair for anyone who could be impacted
um two other conversations that i've had
about this bill were regarding
whether it's in the same town
and i would argue that i don't think it
makes sense to limit this by town
there may be properties that are across
town borders but within the same utility
and i think that using a town border is
somewhat arbitrary so i would say it
doesn't make sense to limit this to just
one town
and the same for the same street address
i think you would need for for a larger
business operation but not a monster
business there may be
you know 100 main street 101 main street
102 main street 103 main street are all
the same owner all the same business you
couldn't just limit it to 100 main
street so
not necessarily the same street address
so think of this as a rough draft in a
conversation
i do think that there's some opportunity
here to make this fair
so it's not just a once a year shifting
opportunity which is what unitil is
doing right now with the business that
i'm explaining about i think this should
be uniform across all businesses
the entire state all utilities and i
think that there's some opportunity here
so with that i'm happy to take some
questions
thank you representative mcwilliams for
introducing this bill
and
thank you for the effort you put into
talking to other people about it to find
out what some of the
questions for improvement might be
i have one as well
did you mean for this bill to apply to
business customer generators only or
were you thinking that any customer
generator would be entitled to this
the provisions of this legislation
the way it's written it doesn't say
business
but we're talking about someone who has
more than one meter
so
i suppose a landlord could have more
than one meter and it's residential but
you could also argue that the landlord
is a business since they're in the
business of renting property
so i don't think the intention is that
this solely applied to businesses the
intention is that it applied to places
where there are more than one meter
okay thank you representative platt is
it recognized yes thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
have you thought about the reaction a
person in the
billing department of utility might have
with something like this it just strikes
me as
blowing their minds
changing from you know one monthly from
one meter to another trying to keep be
able to do that in any kind of
constructive fashion have you have you
had any reaction from the utilities
the great question i have not received
specific feedback from the utilities
regarding billing and i look forward to
okay um
representative
pimentel
and thank you for reminding me to turn
do you get two separate electric bills
or are both meters on the same bill
so full disclosure i actually received
three electric bills um but one is just
for a street light that's pretty typical
for a farm
and i have a follow-up
follow-up
and
your question about whether or not it
would apply to residences
um
i know people who have
two meters one is for their heating
because they're electric heat and they
get a different rate as opposed to
everything else and would that
be something that might be in
reason for allowing them to
have both meters
work for their
electric solar
um so that's a really interesting
proposition i think that for a residence
that has two meters but one is for
electric heat if they're going to do
some kind of energy production whether
it's wind or solar
representative mick williams please
speak into the mic i know you want to
have eye contact with the questioner but
we can't hear you is this better
um
if you have a residence
and they have two meters one of which is
electric uh for electric heat they're
both electricity meters but one's for
electric heat and the other is just for
general use like lighting um
and they're either installing or have
installed
i think there would be a discussion at
the time of installation about applying
the energy
credit to the electric heat account
unless there's a reason
why they wouldn't want to do that so
just out the gate you'd want to be
reducing that bill because obviously
that could be a very heavy load for
residential heat i don't know anything
about the specifics on this constituent
that you're describing
but it makes sense to start out with
reducing the more expensive bill
and then being able to transfer over
some of that surplus to the other bill
so
i guess big picture i think you would
want to start with the electric heat
bill first to be reduced from your
generation
you need a follow-up
okay all right
sorry i forgot representative jackie
i was following you
for a little bit and i was thinking that
you were trying to
help
small businesses
and
homeowners
have you thought about using the word
contiguous property because then it
seems like you could go
you know you talked about towns and
split that's where i lost you
i was thinking of
contiguous property in other words so
your situation would be
that
if if i'm interpreting it correctly
there's a store
and a house and they're on the same
property
have you have you continue considered
that as a beginning
i have considered contiguous property
i think that that still can be limiting
if we're talking about a small business
who has two locations in one town
and they're both owned by the same
person or business name
and they're both under the same utility
and one of them has a solar array
why would we want to say that the second
one couldn't get a credit off of the
bill more than once a year because
they're not contiguous it just seems a
little arbitrary to to insist on having
land location associated with
credit
when
there are two bills you have a surplus
on one they're both bills that are going
to your business why would you want it
follow-up
this marine once said to me at the gate
of a base i am asking the questions lady
what i was not con
contesting the annual
monthly i think is a good idea because
you you're producing every month
but
the contiguous was what i was
thinking on not not the amount that it
would be a year a month quarterly
whatever
that that had nothing to do with what i
was thinking about was contiguous
property so i think contiguous
inherently becomes limiting
because
it means that your business needs to buy
out the neighbor
instead of buying the property three
houses down or you know if we're in a
downtown the property three business is
down it limits your expansion
opportunity because you are also
considering oh the rules say i have to
stay within this footprint and grow as
an amoeba
rather than i'm allowed to hopscotch
around and pick another location to get
the benefit so it seems
a little bit limiting with
with not a good reason why it should be
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman okay so
i've been with you i think it's a good
idea that you should be able to sort of
exercise your credit and if you have
multiple accounts
perhaps um
leverage one credit toward the other
bill
but the thing that i was thinking as i'm
listening to you testify is if you have
a credit on one of the bills
income back like if you have that credit
why does it have to be applied to the
other bill
so just to give an example um i believe
april
if unitil's here they will correct me
but i believe april is the month that
i'm allowed to apply the credit to the
deficit um but i have to report my
earnings for the farm december december
31st
so i've got the solar system cranking
out all kinds of positive energy and
giving me a positive credit on the bill
all summer and even into the fall
so i've racked up a significant chunk of
change that i would love to apply to the
other bill oh but you can't but i can't
by the end of the year i have to hold it
over and then correct it in april the
following year right so from a business
perspective that makes it a little wonky
on the accounting side
and also i would like to actually have
that money that i would be spending on
the second bill
to buy and take care of other things in
the off season during the winter so it
means that those funds that i would be
able to
change move over instead i have to pay
out of pocket and wait to get reimbursed
in april but when we're talking about
the farming season the most important
purchases you make are in january we're
buying lights soil seeds right now but i
can't
spend as much as i would like
because there's this
huge cost on one of my electric bills
and there's this huge credit on the
other electric bill i can't touch right
now so great it just doesn't seem fair
as was you know fairness and also a
uniform policy that's exactly what i was
looking for is because i felt like there
was something missing in here that i
didn't understand about why this would
be of value so that makes perfect sense
okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none we'll now turn to our next
presenter and thank you representative
mick williams thank
you i'd like to call on donna gamache of
eversource
please turn on the microphone
thank you danica bosh with eversource
it's okay representative mick williams
my apologies for not reaching out to you
in advance of the hearing which is
typically what i like to do
not a sob story but
i had an administrative assistant who
retired and now i'm manually going
through hundreds of legislation and
getting feedback and compiling them and
figuring them out so i'm behind very
behind my apologies
i i did not take a position on the bill
the company does not take a position on
the bill but um generally speaking what
we would like to ask for if you decide
to pass this bill is cost recovery um
there are other bills in the legislature
this session to do something very
similar and i've been speaking with the
sponsors of those bills as well as
i've been getting phone calls from some
of the individuals who would be impacted
who've requested the bills and they have
a hard time understanding that currently
we provide credits
to our customer or you know the payout
um once a year and we do it manually we
have we do not have a system in place a
billing system in place to do it because
we don't we have
it's it hasn't grown it's clear to me
that if we start passing all these bills
it will grow because one of this sounds
like a group net what you're trying to
do is group net meter without group net
metering and that's where i think you're
getting the once annually because group
net metering has a specific requirement
versus just regular net metering or just
you having a solar array on your on your
on your property so um we i have tried
to find out exactly what the cost would
be associated with this type of a change
and i've been told that rit department
will not give me
a quote they won't even give me a
bandwidth of an because i tried because
they said they would have to design it
first so what we would have to do is
either design it it would be millions of
dollars or we would have to hire more if
we chose to continue to do it manually
we'd have to hire more people so just
in the event that you do want to pass a
bill like this we would just like to
have an amendment that allows for cost
recovery sad to say but it's it it
appears um over the years that it's um
it's really important when we do go
before the regulator that we're really
explicit so that's why we tend to ask
for cost recovery for this thank you
thank you questions for
ms gamache
i have a question for you you mentioned
that
this bill is attempting to do something
very similar to what group net metering
does could that solve
the problem that representative mick
williams was discussing i think the
problem
what i'm hearing is that group net
metering the the requirements for the
payouts do not align with what she's
looking to do i have another bill that
is trying to make the same kind of a
change for group net metering as well
okay thank you thank you any additional
seeing none
representative oxenum got to raise your
hand a little bit higher
thank you very much
uh just taking advantage of the
opportunity that you're here and if i
may
with your indulgence mr chair let's go
ahead
an issue has arisen
in
two of the four towns i represent
where they are trying to create a solar
array
the one town has the land where a solar
array could go
the other
town has the people who could be off
takers because the little bit of land in
the one town is just over the edge it
has very few people in the territory
so with
with the multiple definitions where it
has to be within the same town has to be
within the same utility et cetera et
cetera et cetera
how
is there a way to resolve this
that would not
prohibit
uh towns the town boundary i i perhaps
it was a prime sponsor who who used the
words that why should the town boundary
be at issue here as long as it's within
the same utility territory and you have
your group host and you have your array
and you have your members
shouldn't that be sufficient
i would have to double check
i really would have to double check on
the group net metering because i'm not
i cannot remember that there is a
requirement that would be in the same
town just as long as it had to be in the
same utility but i would have to double
check
on that i could be wrong um i would have
to i
i would really love to double check that
the other thing that i wanted to throw
out is that um you know group net
metering net metering group net metering
over the years as it's evolved there's
always been this eye toward balance like
balancing the costs for others etc
and
as a result of trying to find that
balance we've seen that there have been
new opportunities open up to do
something that we might not have thought
about before and i'll bet your area has
already thought about this but i wanted
to throw it out anyway maybe community
aggregation using that generator
might might be an opportunity also
i don't know thank you for that and um
our playing field is
pursuing community power aggregation but
unfortunately at least at this point
cornish is not so uh
it gives us an opportunity to encourage
them thank you thank you i'll check on
thank you mr chair for your indulgence
thank you
absolutely i think
statute that we passed last year
might confine it to a single
municipality but i'm not sure that the
other it is and it's between the one and
five megawatts that that applies but i'm
not sure about the the regular group net
metering as opposed to the municipal but
thank you mr chairman
mrs um
uh
gamash
um
on the on the uh cost issue
certainly if you have to do things
manually that's gonna be an ongoing cost
would the software upgrade be like a
one-time
expense is that
would that be correct to assume um it's
a one-time expense to install to design
and install and then they have the
upkeep the uh maintenance of it is so
that's ongoing but we have i mean we
have billing systems now we've upgraded
our billing system a few years ago um so
it's something that we do it's just that
we need to get cost recovery if we're
going to do it again
i got a follow-up
follow-up
and how would that work would you go to
the
puc to
put this into your formula for the
following year that sort of thing so
we'd have to go to the p we'd have to go
to the puc to get approval for doing
what we're doing they'd have to agree
that what we've chosen is the least cost
um because there's probably many ways to
skin the cat and so we'd want to make
sure that we're doing it in the way that
we actually get the desired outcome but
we haven't overspent for nothing so
and then working oh that was another one
i'm glad you asked this question because
i wondered if the um
if we could look at the um the effective
date we might need a little more time
because i mean we have we have half a
million more than a half a million
customers as i said before but some of
the other utilities in the state have
less so the impacts are different for
each of the utilities so it might take a
little longer to figure this one out
thank you thank you
representative plett is recognized for a
question yes thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question ms gamache
the way i understand utility rate making
works is you could be in for a rate case
every five years say
but you spend 300 350 million dollars on
a system in the middle of that
without talking with the commission that
could fall through the cracks right
because you could say well you spent the
money
it's a new rate case doesn't show up in
the test test here that was spent before
so tough luck cookies no bad cookies
right
well i'd say that you're you're
generally correct um we we do our best
to make sure it doesn't fall through the
cracks but we do have to account for
in between the rate cases we have to
account for every decision we make why
made why we did it and why the costs
were what they were and we are always
always every utility is always at risk
of um being denied cost recovery
so
okay
seeing no further questions for
ms gamache i want to thank you for
testifying ms gamache and i want to
thank representative mick williams for
introducing this bill
we have no other pink cards for this
bill so
i'm going to close the public hearing
on
house bill 1116
we will recess until 2 30 at which time
we will take up house bill
oh
okay
does that exist anymore it does very
much
thank you okay
oh
just seizing my opportunity
you know it's the situation you have
like a city like lebanon you know
there's no room
to put up a wind turbine or you know and
it's like you know it has to be within
the municipal boundaries it's like come
[Music]
is
right correct
okay
thank you
hey
okay that's good to know thank you thank
you
hi how are you
good good
so
i'm gonna get it because i promised him
to get that so i'll give it to you too
as a matter of fact right printed this
daily the way center guy remembers it is
uh
[Music]
that's what i think guys said we'll see
foreign
is
oh
um
what's
okay
uh
oh
uh just west of rochester
it's a little west northwest of
rochester okay you know where barrington
is so sea coast yeah well sort of okay
yeah
if you know where barrington is
barrington is drafted houston one town
and they split them in half like in
1820s
my pork
um
uh
wow
right
personally
personally one for you
oh
because
okay
okay it's 2 30
ladies and gentlemen so i would like to
open the public hearing on the next bill
on our agenda which is house bill
1611 relative to the rules of the site
evaluation committee
testifying table the bill's prime
sponsor representative michael
harrington
thank you mr chairman there we go that's
a little better uh i'd like to think
this bill would be totally
uncontroversial but i've been around
here too long to realize that that never
really happens
so
the whole heart of the bill is in line
four if you read it which
it basically says that the site
evaluation committee must reconvene a
rulemaking process to ensure that no
authority is assumed to the committee is
not specifically authorized in rsa162h
now
one would say why do you even need that
since they shouldn't be writing rules
that to implement rsa 162h if they're
not in that law
well because a few years back that's
exactly what happened
i have to admit it was between my stint
at the puc and getting back in the house
i didn't know about it until
it was going to gel car and it was too
late to stop it at that time so the bill
doesn't do anything to change the intent
of the law of rsa 162h it doesn't do uh
it doesn't eliminate or add any new
requirements it's cites a few examples
of where they clearly the site
evaluation committee clearly overstepped
the authority and i don't know why
gelcard didn't pick that up but they
didn't
for example if you look down on line 17
the rule requires all energy facilities
to have an emergency response plan those
words don't even appear there's no
requirement for an emergency response
plan now you may think that's a good
idea or a bad idea but it's the
legislature that decides that not the
site evaluation committee there's a
bunch of well unelected bureaucrats
and um they should be making the
decisions well i'm not going to read the
whole bill to you because the rest of it
basically does the same thing but the
the heart of it is in that uh line four
and five and
i've also been requested a a
another a minor change to this which
would add on to the end
of line five
or which contravenes the declaration of
purpose or requirements of rsa 162h
which just makes it even clearer that
the intent of the rules should be the
rules should reflect the intent of the
law and not what people think might be a
good idea and with that i'll take
questions
thank you could you repeat that text you
want to add to line five please
or which contravenes the declaration of
and i just want to make sure everyone's
clear on this
this doesn't make any changes to the law
whatsoever it just tells the site
evaluation committee hey get it right
this time go make up a set of rules that
comply with the law and not new
requirements that you may must think is
a good idea if they want to make changes
to the law they should petition the
legislature to make those changes but
don't just put in rules that have no
basis in laws because remember once a
rule becomes effective it has the effect
of law
so in effect we've had the site
evaluation committee passing laws
okay thank you can you explain what that
new text or which contravenes the
declaration of the purpose or
requirements it was i received that as a
comment and i think it just tries to uh
bring it uh home
um
a little clearer that it's you know
you're not supposed to be are there any
questions from any members of the
committee about
the purpose of this bill or how it goes
uh representative thomas thank you mr
thank you for taking my question uh i
believe i understand what i heard you
say but for my own clarity
in essence then this bill would
essentially say
any
rules that the site evaluation committee
makes
must be
a direct subset to a law
a state law
it has been directly related to a
specific law that's in the rsa
that is correct what happened was there
was a major change to rsa 162h
most of which addressed new requirements
for wind facilities there was like an
extra
page or two added in specifically for
wind facilities and wind facilities go
implement those and those were the
sections 100 through 300. the problem
was they didn't just implement what was
in the the new law change they put in a
lot of other stuff that doesn't appear
anywhere in the law or appears only for
wind
plants facilities and they applied it to
other non-wind facilities
so this just says go back and get it
right this time
okay thank you you're welcome
uh representative platt is recognized
for a question just making certain i
understand representative harrington
thank you for taking my question this
would require them to go back and review
their rules and take some out that are
not
supported by laws is that correct that
is correct they'd have to make the law
the rules again it's the
ensure that no authority is assumed to
the committee that is not specifically
okay any further questions
representative creation has a question
understanding that gelcar and the
purpose of the site evaluation committee
is to come up with these specific rules
so that we do not have to
list every single thing that you can or
cannot do in statutes so this seems to
me
i don't know i'm
feeling like we're taking um
authority that should proper
expertise that should probably be in gel
car and the sec
and trying to subsume it all directly
into the legislature at this level of
minutia that we're not suited to do
well let me respond to you by this um
without naming anybody's name uh when
this was going to gelcar i called up a
senator who was on gel car at the time
and tried to explain to him uh what my
concerns were and this is almost a
direct quote look we're not changing
anything we don't know what the hell
you're talking about anyways so to say
that there's some expertise on gel car
on site evaluations for energy
facilities is a is a misunderstanding on
your part
and second this gets very specific for
example this isn't like you know have a
rule to implement the following there is
no mention of the word emergency
response plan whatsoever in the uh on
62h and i don't know if you're familiar
with that type of stuff but if you talk
putting an emergency response plan you
can be talking you know 20 30 pages of
requirements and all sorts of uh
protocols on who gets called when and
connections with the with the uh the
police and fire department and they're
going to want to say okay well then we
want to have our own phones or or
whatever or some kind of a direct
communication link and so forth
those were never contemplated in 162
uh h now i'm not saying those aren't
good ideas i'm not saying they're bad
ideas i'm just saying they don't they
don't exist in the law and they were
fabricated by the site evaluation
committee it's not where you can say
well this you said a and we could infer
b we said a and we just made up b so
that's that's why i put this out here
okay can i follow up yes please follow
up um i guess could you give me then an
example of you know something that would
be appropriate for rulemaking authority
what's the point i guess of having the
rulemaking authority under gel car if
we're specifying to them exactly
the limits of what they're doing like
what are they adding to the product
first of all you you back to gel car
again
site evaluation committee
there the rules are to get more specific
and detailed on what is put into the law
so for example if the law said
all energy facilities shall have an
emergency response plan the rules of
which shall be uh developed uh
whatsoever
any facility and they say we're going to
apply this to every facility that's a
major change that could cost the
facility thousands of dollars
and it was never put into the law and
they decided it was a good idea well if
it's a good idea the site evaluation
committee should have come back and
asked someone to submit a change to the
law and then run it through the
thank you you're welcome okay
representative pementel is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative harrington uh
i guess i'm wondering about the fact
that
you're saying that
that other facilities don't
need
site
that as a for instance when
the seabrook power plant was there was
an extensive
emergency response plan that was part of
the
licensing of that facility
is
that
not something
that would be
another energy facility with a
with an emergency spot response plan
well the emergency response plan for
seabrook is
about that high if it was still on paper
and it's thousands and thousands of
pages uh and it involves all sorts of
things that you couldn't even envision i
was involved in developing part of that
and it's required by the nrc to have one
this is what i'm talking about here is
again it's not whether it's a good idea
to have an emergency response plan or
not it's who should make that decision
and the decision is clearly with the
legislature who sets the laws and not
with the site evaluation committee you
know if you took the attitude that they
could do whatever they want they could
come up and say you know every uh win
facility must put down a million dollars
uh in escrow to make sure they have uh
cause no damage in the future and it's
not in the law anywhere they don't have
the authority to do it it's not a matter
of whether it's a good idea or a bad
idea it's whose idea was it and those
ideas are supposed to come through the
legislative process and get passed into
law not go through the rules process the
rules are supposed to be based on the
law
follow up
thank you mr chairman um
i guess i want to narrow down what the
the focus of your bill is
um
they were the sec was supposed to write
rules for
wind generation as i understand it
and
one of their rules was
for a site evalu site
uh
sorry
visual impact assessment the site
uh
emergency plan or whatever
um
and is your is are you saying that they
couldn't do that
either or
that you're
concerned about it being
part of
each
uh and most of it addressed concerns
have been
raised about various wind uh facilities
some of which were you know making sure
they had funding for decommissioning uh
in the future which wasn't in which
wasn't in the law before that and
there's a lot of other proposals
specifically addressing win facilities
now
that's fine they had a rule-making
process and they went through and they
should have implemented those or laws
and put them into rules the fact is they
put him in but they put in a lot of
stuff that wasn't in the law and that's
my concern here it's not the quality of
whether an emergency response plan is a
good idea or a bad idea or whether a
situatis a visual impact assessment or
whether or not they should be a sound
assessment and fire protection plans my
point is the law says they're only to be
applied certain ways and that's the way
the rules should reflect so if you want
to change the law change the law if you
want to write a rule it better follow
i'm not quite following you
because jalkar accepted these jalcock
when a rule is accepted it becomes a
part of the law correct
if you're asking me a question when a
rule is becomes effective it has the
force of law it doesn't become part of
the statute so it has the force of law
and
those rules that
the site evaluation committee
made were they made in response to a
no they were there was a series of win
projects being developed at the time in
the state and there was a lot of
concerns raised at the site evaluation
committee on those projects as far as
like i said decommissioning
uh visual assessments and so forth that
what it wasn't included in the uh law so
it wasn't in the rules either and as a
result of that the law was changed
substantially okay most of it which
addressed dressed win facilities
and then they had to initiate a new
rule-making process to implement those
changes to the law what they did was
they implemented other changes that were
never in the change to the law so this
idea of emergency response plan doesn't
appear in 162h it's not there
the sound assessment is only for wind
energy facilities it's not for solar
and they just they did this and then it
went through the process and as i told
you when when i tried to intervene in
when speaking to people on gel car i was
basically told that we don't know what
the hell you talking about anyway so
follow-up
how long have these rules i mean i was
here in the inception of wind how long
off the top of my head i hope to make i
could only make a guess it's probably
been
i don't know
five or six years i'm guessing is when
that last uh when they went through it
was i know it was in it was the
beginning of it was in january and so it
would have been
thank you you're welcome thank you
representative representative platt
yes thank you thank you for taking a
question representative harrington
you see nothing wrong however with the
let's say say the evaluation committee
sings uh
and
so on to come to the legislature come to
this committee or other appropriate
committees to get law changed to
implement that is that correct
absolutely if they thought it was a good
idea that then they should bring it here
whoops i have a question for you
representative i forgot to turn on the
mic
rsa 541 which is the administrative
under colon free three dash a
this language appears if an agency
proposes a rule pursuant
or a colon 19 the agency shall identify
the specific section
or sections of state or federal statutes
or regulations which the rule is
intended to implement in the notice
required pursuant to
rsa 541a colon
do you interpret that language to mean
that
the authors of rules
have to specifically refer to this or
identify rather the specific section of
state law
when they write that rule
yes i do and as a matter of fact that
was something that i enforced rather
rigorously when i was on the puc and
told people that they had to tie any
proposed rule changes back to statute
thank you
if
a project
has come about
and there are no
state laws referring to that project
such as they would not have been with
nuclear energy they would not have been
with some of the solar things we had
would that project have to be held off
until the
legislature convened and at such time
got together and decided what
these rules should be i seem to think
antrim win
sticks out in my mind
that
there are projects
that the legislature and things
especially energy producers that the la
the legislature had not thought of
but could have been applied in another
situation would you agree with that
well it was actually the site evaluation
rules have been around for quite some
time right
back before the first wind project was
uh
planned for new hampshire
what has happened is the of the
committee and rightfully so has learned
through the project the first one they
had
was a 24 i think was a 24 megawatt
system in the southwest portion of the
state
and then we've had a couple of other
ones since then and the laws were
changed to reflect on some of the
lessons learned during those hearings
but there was a hearing process and
there was rules that governed how those
hearings were tell it's just that
because of what we learned during those
things it was decided to say well we
need to beef up the laws a little bit
more specifically to address wind
but it could be done for any type of
project like that i mean hopefully we
okay did you need a follow-up
representative follow the follow-up
would have been for me could you make
the laws retroactively in other words
the project is approved and the the
project is going on and there are
certain specifications for any project
could you then
say wait a minute
we got to make rules now
and i i think that's
if a project is approved
and then next year you said wait a
minute but this rule
you have to you have to follow this rule
or this law you can't do that
retroactively
so in order for something to go ahead
they would have had to make
specifications and then send them on to
jalka
that's what i would call it a
specification
because one of them
my in my mind when we visited those one
of the major concerns was what happens
when this tower
no longer functional
and in that is one of the things that
was added to the law which is required
for decommissioning the retroactive laws
are generally uh looked on as
non-constitutional certainly i wouldn't
approve of giving somebody approval and
then passing the law a couple years
later saying you have to uh have to
change the way you built it unless there
was a you know a real new safety issue
or something like that that came up but
this this build again it doesn't affect
any specific project whatsoever it's not
going to make anybody
undo anything it just simply says make
the rules match the law
and so if a plant if there's a facility
out there that decides they want to have
an emergency response plan there's
nothing that stops them from having it
they just don't have to have one under
the force of law because the law doesn't
require that it's not in the law
and if you have a solar facility and you
want to put in a do a sound assessment
you can sound assess all you want it's
just not required by the law so this
doesn't undo anything it's not
retroactive
it just says make the law the rules
okay
uh representative creation uh
let's see
is this your second or third question
thank you chair again um thank you for
your indulgence um
so i guess getting back to that question
of whether
these rules are meant sorry uh very
specifically in section 162 h16
it mentions
evaluation for for sites and facilities
generally that the responsibility of the
sec
is to check whether
the facility will have an unreasonable
adverse effect on aesthetics historic
sites etc
um
if i'm understanding your position
correctly you seem to be saying that if
it's not
if we're not being or sorry if we
haven't laid out in an rsa for a very
specific
type of plants that
we have to make rules for for xyz that
they
cannot um
evaluate that
i guess how do you see that as
consistent with 162 h16 well again it
doesn't this would not change the
section of the law that you just read
it's simply you have to understand how
the process worked here this wasn't a
a thing where somebody went up and said
let's make a rule up that it will it'll
do
uh or a law that'll that'll cover all
plan all types of energy facilities
there are requirements in the law that
do affect all types of energy facilities
but the most of these changes were
specifically to wind plants wind
facilities and they were written as a
direct result what was learned in the
previous hearings and they were put in
to address when there was no question
about it that's what the law the intent
of the law was that which is in the law
now if they wanted the site evaluation
committee said well that's such a good
idea we think it should apply to all
types of plants then they should have
come back to the legislature and
requested that they broaden the scope of
the law so that all energy facilities
require that when you have a paragraph
that's simply strictly on wind only and
you list a series of requirements the
intent of the law is that they apply to
the wind and not to the other types of
facilities or they would have been
covered in the other sections of the of
may i just fall out i guess my
understanding of h16 is that they do
apply to all these other
types what would what i don't have like
i said i don't have it memorized
whatever you read on h16 would apply to
all types that is correct yes because
it's it doesn't say wind only okay well
then aesthetics
and environment are covered thank you
representative man next time you ask a
question please turn on your mic oh
pardon me
yeah i was wondering couldn't the rule
be justified by
some law that isn't specific to wind or
to
uh new facilities but rather um
more generals applying to just in
electric supply a safety
issue or something like that in other
words
when you
when you say these things are not there
might be a rule that is not supported by
law how far back
can you go in the law to look for some
justification for
that rule
well
excuse me
and in this case it was it was pretty
easy to do because the legislature
passed a major change to 162h
and they specifically to address wind
facilities that was the major change
that was done and as a direct result of
that new rules were written and they
were written as in most laws say you
know the site evaluation committee will
write rules to implement this law and
they did specifically to implement that
change to the law so it's pretty easy to
say that
the rules should be reflecting what was
changed in the law now as far as going
back or more general things i don't
think you have to do it in this case
because we know specifically why the
rules were being changed they were
did you have a follow-up representative
man okay don't forget to turn off your
mic
um
any additional questions for
representative harrington
seeing none i thank you representative
harrington for
presenting your bill and
testifying it
and i will now call our next
presenter on this subject
and that is lori lerner
who hails from bridgewater
new hampshire and she's here
representing herself
and she opposes this bill
sure
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to speak today in opposition
to this bill 1611. i was the president
of new hampshire win watch and actively
involved during the time of significant
procedural changes to the site
evaluation committee the statute and the
rules and that was guided by senate bill
99 senate bill 281 and senate bill 245.
that was a culmination of efforts
between a a lot of public
involvement sp 99 and 245
were not specific to any particular
energy type facility
sb 281 was specific to industrial wind
these bills were enacted in an effort to
restore the public trust in the sec
process and to provide for greater
public transport transparency and
involvement
that process consisted of
a very large statewide effort to get a
survey of people
from there we went to a pre-rule-making
effort
and again that was considering all types
of energy facilities from there we
drilled into that
to a rule-making process
and then it went on to the adoption of
the rules
hb 1611 recommends a review of the sec
rules based on a misguided assertion the
rules were adopted that were not
specifically authorized by rsa 162h
i strongly disagree with this assertion
first item was the adjudicative hearing
prior to exemption
corresponding authority within rsa 162 h
colon 4
section 4
states in cases where the committee
determines that other existing statutes
provide adequate protection of the
objectives rsa 162 h1 the committee may
within 60 days of acceptance of the
application or filing of a request of an
exemption with sufficient information to
enable the committee to determine
whether the proposal meets the
requirements set forth and hold a public
hearing in a county where the energy
facility is proposed and on it goes
additionally rsa 162 h10
states
subsequent public hearings shall be in
the nature of adjudicative proceedings
under rsa
541-a
for this reason i do believe that the
rules correspond to our statute moving
on to visual impact assessment there's
corresponding authority within 162h
which applies to all energy facilities
in the declaration of purpose it states
the legislature recognizes the selection
of sites for energy facilities may have
significant impacts on and benefits to
the following
and one of those is aesthetics within
the application for certificate section
it requires the energy facility to
provide such additional information as
the committee may require to carry out
purposes of this chapter
and this chapter continues on with the
findings and certificate issuance and
within that
it states the science facility will not
have an unreasonable adverse effect on
aesthetics
some additional background
senate bill 99 directed the office of
energy and planning to conduct public
stakeholder pre-rule making process to
help develop regulatory criteria for the
siting of energy facilities
to inform an sec rulemaking process
as a result of the rule making on page
four of the document where the footnote
is it specifically states general
agreement was reached by a group that
some level of visual impact analysis
should be required for all proposed
facilities and the rules should allow
flexibility in the level of the via
based on the type and level of impact
this is precisely what has been defined
by rule 301.05
effect on aesthetics
moving on to the next item
sound assessment and fire protection
plan
first of all there's an erroneous
reference it references section c
instead of d
but overlooking that within the
declaration of purpose
there's a statement of the statement
goes on the legislature can recognizes
the selection of sites for energy
facilities may have significant impacts
on the on and benefits to the following
and one of those items is public health
and safety
again
application for certificate specifically
states provides such additional
information as the committee may require
to carry out purposes of this chapter
in the findings
it must be determined the site and
facility will not have an unreasonable
adverse on public health and safety
additionally
301.081 states accept as otherwise
provided
in a1 above an assessment of the
operational sound associated with the
proposed facility if the facility would
involve the use of equipment it might
reasonably be expected to increase sound
by 10 decibel
measured at the l 90 sound level this
was incorporated to make sure there was
no public health or safety concern over
any particular noise from any type of
energy energy facility
so again it should be noted it's only
required if it would introduce excess of
10 dba above background levels this
would apply to a substation used for any
facility and any other facility which
will potentially introduce excessive
sound emissions
a fire protection plan is relevant for
all energy facilities included but not
limited to transmission lines in light
of the known wildfire hazards
experienced in the forest and in brush
areas
the emergency response plan much as
above
has the same statutory authority as
described in the sound assessment and
fire protection plan an emergency
response plan is relevant for the same
reasons specified for the fire
protection plan which is for the event
of
a forest fire a brush fire or any other
type of fire
conclusion for the reasons identified
above i disagree with the assertion the
statutory authority was exceeded and
recommend this bill be itled
thank you very much
okay thank you for that excellent
testimony i appreciate that
do we have questions for ms lerner
representative platt has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if you're right
and this law passes
then wouldn't the result be the site
evaluation committee going through every
one of its rules and saying it this is
how it's tied to law with no change in
if i understand your question correctly
i strongly believe that everything in
the rules was tied directly back to the
statute
my question was wouldn't they find that
then going through the rules yes yes yes
they would in a trace back through the
complete sb99 281 and 245 process
through the sb pre-rule-making and onto
okay
additional questions for ms lerner
if i can just add one thing
so this this was a bit of an
extraordinary circumstance given the
times that we were faced with between
northern pass and industrial wind
coming down within our state and at that
time there was a huge eruption of public
interest in all of this
and so the there was no way that the
legislature could outline in the statute
every single specific change which is
why there was a lot of
time and effort spent hiring outside
experts to help with this entire process
and i strongly believe that it follows
the statute
in the intent of it
and
everything can be traced back to that
thank you for the opportunity
uh i have a question if someone else
does
nature of sec projects which are very
legalistic in that they examine
in minute detail
statutory requirements and rules
requirements
and apply them to
wouldn't the result
be litigation
if
a project
if a project developer determined
that
the rules as written didn't match
the statute
that authorized those rules wouldn't
there be likely be litigation that would
happen and has any such litigation
happened with regard to sec rules i'm
not familiar with any litigation i will
also say that the stakeholder process
included
a lot of
participants from industry so we had
participants from eversource unitil
industrial wind facilities
every type of facility was represented
on on the scc rulemaking process and
then on to the rule making process so
there was a lot of feedback and input
that went through to develop these rules
see no further questions for ms lerner i
will now move on to our next presenter
and that is lisa knows of lyman new
hampshire who's here to represent
herself
ms leno's thank you nice to see you
again
thank you mr chair vice chair thomas and
members of the committee
for the record my name is lisa linos i'm
a resident of the state of new hampshire
i have appeared as an intervenor before
the site evaluation committee numerous
times and also as an expert witness
the i do i am speaking in opposition to
1161.
i'm sorry
1611. that's a typo my the premise is uh
ms lerner stated it appears to be that
the sec has exceeded its authority in
adopting certain rules
and um i have two
main points i want to make i won't get
into the details as to what um
the bill says but i will speak to the
fact that everything that has been
stated as potentially exceeding the
authority of the sec in fact is
supported by 162h
so during the rulemaking process this
would be an sec docket
201404 so it happened over the
2014-2015 time frame
the rules show that the sec was very
careful to ensure it followed the
explicit language of 162h
in areas where the language was not
specific the sec
assessed and showed where its actions
were consistent with legisl the
legislative intent under sb 245. that's
a critical component there and i'll come
back to that in a moment
so my the first point i wanted to make
and miss leonard lerner mention it but i
want to emphasize it
um hb 16 take 11 16 11 takes objection
to the fact that an applicant who
chooses to have or wishes to have his
application exempt it from the sec
process in 162h
the sec rules state that an adjudicative
hearing has to be conducted
this state the legislature i'm sorry 162
h
the law
this would be colon 4
says that a public hearing will be held
and it appears that representative
harrington
has said that a public hearing
it does not necessarily imply an
adjudicative hearing okay
but
under rsa 162 h10
which is titled
public hearings public hearing studies
and rules
it establishes for the sec
that the only time the committee will
conduct a public hearing that is
non-adjudicative
is when it is holding a joint meeting
after an application has been accepted
and it's the joint meeting is between
the agencies and the sec
at a public meeting
at a public hearing before the public in
the county in which the application
application is proposed to be cited
it all it says
all subsequent
hearings public hearings of the
committee are to be adjudicated hearings
that's it it doesn't show and they're
only there are no other public hearings
that are not declared as adjudicative
unfortunately the language of 162h may
be confusing there because it doesn't
really consider out-of-order
applications in this case and in a case
where an applicant is petitioning to
have his application exempt from the sec
process
he comes in files the petition
and then says that i i you know can you
take
the bottom line is the sec will hold an
adjudicated hearing to make a
determination
again it doesn't explicitly say in 162h
that in that case it's an adjudicative
hearing
what it says is in that case it's a
public hearing elsewhere in the law it
says all public hearings but for the
informational hearing that occurs but
public hearing that occurs
prior to the
fully judicial process all public
hearings will be adjudicative
so you may want to make an adjustment to
language on 162h there but that is
clearly where the sec is coming from
when it is following an adjudicative
adjudicative process
with regard to legislative intent on
that point 160 sb 245 made an explicit
change to the law
prior to sb245 passing
the law had said
that the sec will only hold a public
information hearing to determine whether
or not an application can be exempted it
explicitly changed as the legislature
explicitly change the language from a
public information hearing to determine
exemption to a public hearing
so i just want to make that point there
there was a change by the legislature
the intent
appears clear
with regard to sections 2 b c and d in
i would like to draw your attention to a
november 25th 2015 letter that sec chair
martin horningberg sent to jail car this
is when
we were the the process had been coming
to a close
and uh the first draft rules or proposal
had been sent that were deemed to be
final believed to be final were sent to
jail car and jail car issued a
preliminary objection to the 2015 final
rule proposal
and in that case djokar's concern was
that the sec had exceeded its authority
when it defined
definition of public use criteria
because the new law under sb245 it said
that the project had to show
that it would be in the public interests
and i'm so now public use probably be in
the public interest the sec through the
rulemaking process had to find what it
meant to be in the public interest
jail car objective
so chairman oneenberg's response to joe
carr which is this is i could send you
the link uh chairman bose to this letter
but it's right on the sec website
his response to jail card addressed the
immediate concern regarding the public
interest question and he also added this
statement which responds directly to the
issues raised by 11 by 16 11.
and this is quote we note further that
sb 245 in addition to requiring the sec
fine the issuance of a certificate will
serve the public interest
also amended rsa 162 h16
to include the following sentence
after due consideration in this
descendants after due consideration of
all relevant information regarding the
potential sighting or roots of a
proposed energy facility including
potential significant impacts and
benefits the site evaluation committee
shall determine if issuance of a
certificate will serve the objectives of
this chapter
if you look at footnote in in the
document i handed you the footnote
below shows what the original wording
was before sb 245 is written so the all
relevant information is important
then he goes on to say sb 245 also
amended the sec rulemaking mandate in
rsa 162 h10 7 to require that the sec
adopt rules relative to the criteria for
citing energy facilities including
specific criteria to be applied in
determining if the requirements of rsa
162h have been met by the applicant for
the certificate of site and facility
notably he goes on this amendment
brought in the scope of the rulemaking
directive to adopt specific criteria to
encompass all of rsa 162 h16s
including the public interest finding
that's what i believe representative
harrington is missing it was there were
two laws
s two bills sb
sp 245 required rulemaking be introduced
and open and they expanded the
rulemaking requirement
sb 281 was an additional law that said
oh in addition to these rules we want to
make sure you don't forget about the win
question and then it articulated some of
the concerned concerns of a win
it doesn't mean that what was applied
for win was not to apply that they were
forbidden to apply those similar kinds
of uh criteria to other applications it
was the other way around 245 came first
281 came later
although they were
filed around the same time in other i
rather it could come much later but the
same year
in other words the legislative intent
intent of sb 245 is interpreted by the
sec
and accepted by gel card this letter was
sent to gel card gel card didn't turn
around and said no you misread at 245's
intent
jail card accepted this sentence
and
the this interpretation
of legislative intent was for the sec to
develop specific criteria for all energy
facilities when making a finding of no
unreasonable adverse effects
contrary to the claims of
hb 1611 the sec acted properly it
appears hb 1611 fails to fully
understand the existing language and
authorities of the sec as granted with
the passage of sbg45
and i encourage this committee to oppose
okay thank you for that testimony
uh ms lerner now we're going to find out
if the committee
has any specific questions for you about
and it would appear that nobody does
i do have a question
could you
help refresh our memory as to exactly
when
the bills that you mentioned
sb 245 sb 99 and sb 281
win those bills what what legislative
i i believe that was 2014. i it may have
been introduced in 2013 but adopted in
2014 as part of the 2013-14 and 281
281 i'm going to ask lori lerner that
so the year was 2014 for both of those
bills how about senate bill 99
representative notter is recognized for
a question thank you i'm just going back
in my head do you remember who the
chairman was that year
there was a woman from the east uh
coastal area and i'm
that ultimately was involved with 245
when that passed and i don't remember
her name
senator fuller clark
no i know who you mean
she was small built slight billed white
hair yes yes i remember
i'm drawing a blank on his name but i
remember who you who you met yeah
uh representative
partial
thank you chair and thank you for your
testimony would you mind forwarding a
copy of your testimony to the committee
for those of us who may not have
received it yes and i will amend it so
it includes the link to
chairman honenberg's letter so that you
can see that excellent thank you thank
you it went several rounds to jail clerk
i mean this was controversial the entire
process was controversial and gelcar
went around
at least two or three rounds
and mr chairman if i may add when the
question was asked if this bill passed
what's the problem they're all they're
going to find the same outcome that
we're talking about it's a question of
time and wasting time that's a worry and
it's it's already been done it's been in
place for since 20 december 2015 was
when the rules were adopted
okay
okay thank you
any further questions for ms lerner
or miss uh leno's rather either of them
in fact
seeing none i thank you both for your
testimony and we'll move on to our
final testifier on this uh question
man
oh it's jim monahan okay jim i didn't
recognize how you uh
your handwriting is uh not as not as
could you turn on your microphone yeah
uh yeah anyway i won't say the whole
thing i'm jim monahan with the dupont
group and i'm here on behalf of the new
england power generators association
it's in that capacity we often help
clients move through the site evaluation
committee process
i didn't check off support or oppose yet
on this bill because we're still digging
into it
but we have been watching the work that
representative harrington has been doing
on taking a hard look at the site
evaluation committee and i certainly
don't want to come here today and say
that
the system is perfect
and probably does need some reforms it's
to take into account what we've learned
since some of these
laws have been passed and people have
been moved through them um the
interesting part of this bill and this
is where we want to dig into a little
bit and it sounds like the folks behind
me have a bit already that the child car
process if you've ever been through it
you know is a cakewalk this is a
cakewalk compared to the child car
process because the attorneys did you
know dig into everything that comes
before the job car and
as has been observed associated every
rule with a statutory authority to do it
but i do want to take a hard look at the
three four provisions in this bill to
see what they pointed to
i suspected in part
uh it is uh what is generally reviewed
to as the four part test at the site
evaluation committee for before a
certificate can be issued and my
computer battery died so i can't give
you the specific site but
um
the the four parts typically
um the four-part test are you know does
the developer have the financial
wherewithal to uh develop the project
um is it being developed uh in a uh
in a manner that's uh reasonable for the
uh regional development and that in that
instance they have to take into account
uh municipal concerns and uh regional um
development concerns
and then the third part uh is uh there's
a little bit of a
a list of things that have to be
proven if you're going to get your
certificate among those are that
it doesn't interfere with the aesthetics
of the region and that it takes into
account public safety
when it um and i suspect that part of
that and then the fourth part is that
it's in the public interest and that was
addressed
here
um what's
helpful to a developer when they're
going through the site evaluation
process is trying to better understand
what things like aesthetics and public
safety mean that type of predictability
helps a project get through the process
because they can point to
meeting a specific test and so the
rules that are identified around
aesthetics and in
uh fire protection that are identified
in the bill i think are probably fall
under that category of that important
test now i'll go back and dig into it
and see if it's it's the case
uh if it's not then you know uh you know
you have to take a hard look at what the
the gel card did but i suspect that
whatever commissioner hornenberg at the
time pointed to
uh was something that met their test
um and then finally i would just echo
what others have said that i am
concerned about uh the practical effects
of this because we're essentially asking
the site evaluation committee to police
themselves and come back and say that
the rules are consistent with you know
how they proposed them in 2014 or 2015
or whatever it is it will be a time
consuming process um
so with that i'll answer any questions a
lot in a lot has been
addressed that i would have raised
anyway from from other speakers but you
know i enjoy working representative
harrington and i do think there's
opportunities to make things better at
the site evaluation committee um and so
and i think there's another more
comprehensive study commission that's
being proposed too which may be the
better way to look at some of these
things
okay thank you any uh questions for mr
monaghan
representative oxenam
thank you very much mr chair thank you
for taking my question
you kind of sped up there at the end and
and
if you could just back up on the last
two points that you made
uh one was about the sec having to
vet itself did i get the verb right
uh perhaps i think what i was saying is
and representative votes made this
observation too that what the bill is
asking the site evaluation committee to
do is to go in and
i guess kind of audit its rules to make
sure that they're operating properly
under the statute
um you know i'd be surprised if they
came back and said
and then the other point that i had
trouble with you said that you you
recognize that this might be an
opportunity to make things better but
that
was was it a time concern that you what
were you going to get much bang for the
buck if if you
imposed this audit on the sec i would
was that right i guess i'm not exactly
sure that that's what i was saying so i
apologize if i spoke too fast what i'm
saying is that you know that may be an
opportunity to take a more comprehensive
look at the site evaluation committee i
know representative i think
representative harrington has filed a
bill on that front i know there was a
study committee that i sat in on
this last summer that raised some larger
issues
this these issues might be better raised
in that context and and
just just to clarify go ahead follow up
i had a little trouble maybe it's my
hearing
did this other body or other group that
is looking at a more comp could you just
repeat that uh what i'm saying is i
underst i believe that representative
harrington has filed another piece of
legislation
or perhaps not well there was a study
committee
um uh this past summer that took a hard
look at the site evaluation committee
and i
and i apologize i'm looking at like now
i don't know if that bill was actually
filed
it's a senate bill okay
there are actually two senate bills
one senate bill both are sponsored by
representative i mean senator gaida and
representative harrington and myself are
co-sponsors of both bills
and one bill sets up a committee
to look at a long-term restructuring of
the site evaluation committee
and the second bill
makes
numerous i can't remember exactly how
many a dozen or more
changes to rsa h162
to
improve the short-term operation
of the site evaluation committee
i don't think any of those changes in
the second bill that i just mentioned
address any of the issues that
this bill
addresses
only peripherally if if at all but
that's what those other two bills do
so the one question i would have for you
just to to wrap things up here is
do you think
as it's currently written 162 h
provides adequate definitions of what it
means by aesthetics and public health
and safety
in order for
precise rules to be written
around those
concepts
there do need to be administrative rules
so that there's predictability for
developers about what aesthetics and
public safety mean
and
subject to check with my clients that
have moved through the process are
getting ready to move through the
process
uh the rules about visual impacts and
then uh the other rule here with regard
to
fire protection things like that make it
easier for a developer to say i have met
the test
of of the of you know part three of the
four-part test
okay good representative plett has a
question
yes thank you
what i'm hearing about some of these
rules and the way we're written aren't
they couldn't they be a death knell to
any project
nobody nobody beats any kind of uh
visual or
impact or well for all the bad rap the
sec has gotten i've only seen one
project denied i mean most get through i
mean it's a challenge
um
but no so i don't
many don't develop because they don't
get that far representative i think
that's a fair observation but i'm not
sure that
these will constitute a death note
but
i can certainly consult with a developer
that decided not to go forward because
they couldn't meet a you know one of the
tests
representative callie
pitts mr monaghan
in
energy facilities and i i know
just as a simple yes yes or no
are there certain federal rules that
supersede
what the state might want are there
federal regulations concerning the
construction and operation
of
energy facilities
okay we're going to uh
wrap it up with that answer to the
question we appreciate your testimony mr
monaghan
and i am going to close the public
hearing on house bill 1611
and i will then immediately
which is house bill
relative to power line maintenance
and i'm hoping that representative
baruti is here to introduce the bill i
believe he is so we'll call on
representative baruti and say welcome to
science technology and energy sir
thank you mr chairman um i don't get a
chance to come here that often
um but for the record my name is
benjamin beruti uh hillsboro 43 which is
manchester's awards
four five six and seven
this is a pretty simple bill that was
written wrong so you do have an
amendment
we crossed out the wrong part
what we crossed out was
and is approved by the utilities which
was never intended to be crossed out
and what was intended to be crossed out
is what's in the
the new bill that's just been approved
and it starts with licensed licensed in
the state of new hampshire
what that means is
you know if you see a line truck with a
couple linemen on it
chances are
they might not be licensed because
they're not required to be
the only time
alignment is required to have a license
is if he's working beyond the primary
meter box
up until the primary meter box
a lot of them are not licensed
and that's
that's the whole gist of this um
they don't if we can get into more but
that that's what it means
uh they're not required
the utility company i mean the
subcontractor whoever it is
does have to be approved by the utility
company
okay thank you obviously a relatively
simple bill but maybe more questions are
needed to understand exactly what it's
for so representative platt wanted to
lead us off thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question representative
rudy the purpose of this uh is to why
why
is it to speed things up is it to save
money why why introduce this change well
if this is the law right now
you have a lot of people working for the
utility companies and subcontractors
that
are
working against the law
sorry
representative harrington is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so i'm just trying to
make sure i get this straight then what
you're saying is if we
if there's going to be a power line
extension done on private property
and that extension is done by utility
personnel
they may not be licensed electricians
but if a contractor is hired to do it
under present law they would have to be
licensed electricians well that i think
the way i read it anybody
working on that power line has to be
licensed
well this says a utility customer that
requires a power line extension located
on private property may hire a
contractor who was okay yeah
so but these um
these subcontractors who work for
companies all over
not only the people in the state but
say you have a power outage and you
bring people in from out of state
massachusetts new york
north carolina ohio canada
all of these people you don't expect
okay who's next uh there must be a
million questions about this bill
uh representative callie pitts i just
representative buru i just didn't
understand what you said
it's late in the day
if somebody if we have an emergency and
crews come in from
different places
um
you would expect that they
wouldn't be
licensed no not necessarily well they
probably wouldn't be but
it's it's not required
so i mean
chances are they're not
holding a new hampshire license
but
they have a working agreement with other
new hampshire has a working agreement
with other states
excuse me canada and everything so those
people you know won't have a license
but it's not required the only thing
that's required is
the subcontractor is approved by the
follow-up
a follow-up excuse me it's the sun if
some if
if i was
learning the business
and i was working
under
a licensed
contractor
i i wouldn't be licensed
right well first of all they're not
licensed contractors they're approved
contractors
the the contractors aren't licensed
they're approved they're approved yes
it's almost like if you're brand new
it's like going through an apprentice
program there's steps there's different
steps
first class second class third fourth
class lineman
and that's
like a private contractor would have a
manual that they
they send into the department of labor
that they go by and how they
promote their people and
i believe the labor department could do
it but i don't know if they anybody does
it through the labor department
everybody likes to train their own
people
probably for insurance reasons to make
sure
they don't get whacked with a big
representative pementel is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative ruby
i i guess i'm a little bit lost on what
i i'm wondering
are you trying to make sure that
all people who are working on on a line
extension are licensed
no
no it's not required
and but the way
the way this isn't a statute now
it it alludes to they have to be
licensed when
right now a lot of people out probably a
third of the people working out there
are not licensed
okay
if he doesn't the follow-up is
uh because we're not looking at what's
being changed we're looking at
because we haven't seen the amendment
how does your bill
change it
so that it
does it does allow people
it's scratch's uh requirement for the
license all right i have a follow-up
question
um
contractor who is licensed in the city
uh
you're
according to this you're not really
requiring them to be
not only not licensed in new hampshire
but they don't have to be licensed in
any other state no okay
thank you okay representative oxenam has
a question
well i almost thought that i wasn't
going to need to follow up because he
was going to clarify it so let's let's
just just you know we've got the bill
we've got the amendment what you're
trying to do is just clean up the
statute because it says people have to
be licensed and in fact they don't
that's a correct right thank you so much
sir okay
thank you so representative thomas has a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
if the
if if we were to introduce the uh your
suggested amendment
um
are you
um one of my questions
so the utilities would have to approve
the person doing the work on the grounds
uh am i to assume that the utilities
have their own criteria for having
licensed people to do work that that
that they would prove
well the way i understand it is a
utility
would approve a contractor
the contractor is the one who does the
training
and does the promotions and whatever
so that
really the the subcontractor is the one
that is responsible
um
but they don't have a license but they
are they're approved
so the individual is not approved but
the company is
i have a follow-up
follow-up
okay
i
my question was really
do utilities
require their contractors to be licensed
to do work that they approve on
no
okay they just they just have to approve
them
okay who's next representative creation
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question hi neighbor
um i guess my question so i'm not
intimately familiar with this rsa but i
did notice that this bill is only
pertaining to the installation of power
line extensions um is there
i guess is there anything else in this
rsa that should also be amended at the
same time or is there any reason that
this was exclusive to the you know
extending of the line to the house
um
i think this is adequate i mean it's
it's what's being done now is um they're
not
they're not licensing people now so this
is
uh
anybody working maybe working breaking
the law if they're not licensed so
that's why we tried to clean it up a
little bit
okay
additional questions
it seems to me like an obvious question
here is would a utility approve a
contractor who's not licensed
no they they approved the they approved
the contractor
okay so the question remains
if i'm going to hire a contractor and
i've got two guys who come to me and one
guy has a license and one guy doesn't
and i'm a utility
am i going to hire the guy who doesn't
have a license
well i think they just put everything
out to bid but anyone they hire is on
their approved list usually
if they approve you you're an approved
contractor
and by approving a contractor you're
approving
the people who work for that company
so another way to ask the question then
would be would a utility approve a
contractor who's not licensed
no
no i mean if they're
well
there is no license
representative pimentel you had a
question
thank you mr chairman that's similar to
but essentially where would somebody
need a license if
um i mean what is this license for
the only time
the only time you would need a license
is if you're working beyond the meter
box
like the line will come in and then if
you work on the other side of the box
that's when you need a license
because the utility is not responsible
they own the line
the line goes in and once it hits that
box
utility is not responsible anymore
whoever works inside that
now that person has to be licensed
follow up
thank you mr chairman so essentially
linemen are not normally
electricians they're not they have an
electric
electrician's license
and they're allowed
to wire up to the meter itself but
beyond that
then you need a license a licensed
electrician yeah that's correct but a
lot of them do get licenses because
they're working with electricity so but
they don't they have a lot of friends
who need help
okay okay representative harrington has
a question
not so much of a question maybe there's
a clarification that might help okay
i've seen at my own house the power
lines come down because of ice storms
and the person who came back up and put
it up was i assume approved by the
utility but they also didn't speak
english because they were from canada so
would it be safe to assume
representative harrington that that
person from canada has some
uh
training oh i'm sure that work he was
driving a hydro quebec truck and i
assume he did the similar work in canada
but just during that ice storm he was
down in the united states like were a
lot of canadians to help us restore our
power here so this was not unique to my
house i'm sure it was done all over the
state
they have a reciprocal agreement
so that gets us back to the original
question way back at the beginning of
this hearing
why do we need this legislation what's
the purpose of it because right now
there are some people out there working
probably working even for a utility
i apologize
i've heard a couple times you're saying
some people are breaking the law do you
have any uh
um actual evidence of how many people
are pulling lines in new hampshire um
are not uh certified depot lines because
i understand there's a certification
program
no they're all working under some kind
they're not licensed but they're working
under a program
like when you're working on your
certification the day you're hired
you go into a training program
you know and you're like a third class
lineman or a fourth class lineman and
you're working with somebody who's
teaching you to trade
after you get to a certain point you
take tests then you can get promoted
which means a raise and
whatever and it it there's no time limit
on it you have to qualify to get the
promotion and i think every company
might be different but that's normally
how it works
but you're saying that's now do i
understand correctly i'm sorry i have a
go ahead um
but you're saying now there are many
people who do not hold that
certification who are out work
well i'm trying to use language i don't
think our linemen actually license are
they certified
electrician electricians are certified
and there is no license there is no
license
and that's what's confusing about this
you have license in this in this in the
statute
when they there is no license well they
are certified though they might not be
licensed but they are certified with
their company yep and their company is
also approved by the utility
okay so this will not be removing any
any requirements for certification
that's
removing requirements for a licensing
which does not exist right
okay thanks you've clarified it greatly
okay any uh any further questions for
representative baruti
representative callie pitts
some years ago we passed a license
requirement for somebody who puts in
solar panels
now that's on the roof
and that's got to be a licensed
electrician correct and that still holds
yeah so you're not going to get me to
put
10 000 volts in your house and blow it
up
is that correct we're still going to
have that requirement for licensed
electricians
yeah this seems to apply only to
installation of power line extensions
has nothing to do with installations of
solar
panels
extension
could be
what they're doing with the new grid
right with redundancy
some companies
and i know this from personal experience
like new hampshire electric co-op
will bring the power up to the head of
your driveway but let's say you have a
driveway that's
600 700 feet long
and you need to get the power down to
your house
and you need maybe two or three poles to
get it down there
the utility will charge you like a
thousand dollars a poll
to do that power line extension
but you can hire a private contractor to
do that extension and they might do it
for five hundred dollars a poll
so i think that's what we're talking
about here with power line extensions
i i know someone who actually did that
at his house and he saved a lot of money
by hiring a private contractor
i'm still unclear about
the whole issue of certification or
licensing of these people but apparently
new hampshire electric utility
the co-op said yeah that person can put
in the lines and we'll will supply the
power
but
i believe i'm correct aren't i
representative
yeah okay
all right any further uh questions any
information gathering we can do on this
subject
seeing none i would thank you uh
representative baruti for bringing your
bill to us okay thank you very much
we'll see you on another occasion i
suspect i don't know i don't come here
that often
well you're welcome at any time so this
stuff's too technical for me
okay
i have no other pink cards on this
subject
so with that
we'll close the public hearing on house
bill
1331.
and i will thank
all of my uh all committee members for
your participation in today's activity
we uh we learned a lot about 5g and
timber um
doomage
and other subjects
so i thank you all and we'll see you
again next tuesday the 25th of january
when we will he'll hear five more bills
the first of which will be a two-hour
public hearing
on
pfas
limits air emissions
is
uh